the final season of Game of Thrones has
arrived but before we can get to the
ending first we have to understand the
beginning we've got the whole history of
Westeros mapped out for you just in time
to get ready to see it all come crashing
down here's the entire game of thrones
timeline explained in the distant past
Westeros was the home of the children of
the forest but roughly 12 000 years
before the first episode of the series
takes place the first humans arrived
from across the sea the children of the
forest called them the first men and two
thousand years of war and suit finally a
truce was called but it was too late the
children turned to dark magic to protect
themselves and inadvertently created the
undead night King and his white walkers
once The Pact was signed around 10 000
BC the first men entered the age of
Heroes with legendary figures like bran
the Builder and land the clever creating
much of what defines Westeros as we know
it but the age of Heroes is defined most
by the long night around the year 8000
BC the white walkers Broke Free from the
control of the children of the forest
bringing about a winter a Perpetual
night that lasted an entire generation
in that Darkness the white walkers came
for the first time they swept through
cities and kingdoms riding their dead
horses the children and first men banded
together to defeat the night King but at
Great cost the children were nearly
driven to Extinction and the wall was
built to keep the Walkers trapped in the
Frozen North along with the tribes of
humanity who would become the wildlings
our clearest glimpse of this era comes
from the season 7 episode The Spoils of
War in which Jon Snow and Daenerys
examined cave paintings beneath
Dragonstone of the Walkers the children
and the first men starting around 6 000
years in the story's past a new group of
human Invaders arrived the Andals
originally from essos the Andals were
compelled by visions of a seven-faced
God to cross the sea and settle Westeros
their religion which became the faith of
the seven spurred social developments
like Knighthood and chivalry the first
man pushed out by the waves of Andals
arriving over the course of several
thousand years slowly retreated to the
north where their Traditions were kept
by families like the Starks and the
mormonts still to people from essos
anyone from Westeros is considered to be
an andal which is why even North men
like Jorah are given that nickname by
those who don't know any better
where are the dragons
will you betrayer again Jorah the undo
speaking of essos that continent
developed very differently than Westeros
thanks to The Magicians and Dragon
Riders of legendary valyria
they developed the dragon view Stone
roads which still crisscross essos and
invented Valyrian steel the strongest
metal ever known but roughly 400 years
before the events shown in Game of
Thrones all of that ended with the Doom
of Illyria a cataclysmic volcanic
disaster that left the fabled empire in
Ruins magnificent
looks fresh forged you do no one's made
a Valyrian steel swords as a doom of
valyria among the only survivors were a
minor family called the targaryens who
had left essos for the castle
Dragonstone in Westeros 12 years earlier
after a prophetic dream warned them of
becoming Doom the targaryens were
suddenly the survivors of a lost culture
and among the few people in the world
with dragons at their beck and call
though the forces of the targaryens were
puny compared to the great houses of the
Seven Kingdoms they held the trump card
three great dragons written by aegon the
Conqueror and his two Sister Wives aegon
United the Seven Kingdoms under his rule
creating the Iron Throne out of the
swords they surrendered to him in the
year 280 the seeds of the Targaryen
downfall were sown the Mad King heiress
Targaryen decided to marry off his son
in Heir the Beloved Prince rhaegar to
the dornish Princess Elia Martel the
sister of Prince Doran and Oberyn
Martell but rhaegar secretly was in love
with lyanna star the betrothed of Robert
Baratheon in the year 281 Prince rhaegar
won a tournament at Herron Hall but
instead of naming his wife as the
tournament's queen of love and beauty he
chose lyanna driving a wedge between
house Baratheon and the targaryens and
they weren't alone breaking tradition
the Mad King named Tywin Lannister's son
Jaime Lannister as one of his King's
Guard forcing Jaime to renounce his
claim as heir to House Lannister Tywin
was enraged and resigned as the hand of
the king retreating to casterly rock
that set the stage for everything that
has happened in the show since in the
year 282 rhaegar had his marriage
annulled and secretly wed lyanna the
starts though believing lyanna was
captured against her will protested to
the Mad King in a fit of rage the king
murdered Lord Rickard and his eldest son
Brandon Stark Brandon's brother Ned
joined with Robert Baratheon in
Rebellion your father and brother rode
South once
on a king's demand during Robert's
rebellion rhaegar was killed by Robert
Baratheon but not before lyanna became
pregnant Ned Stark found her on her
deathbed having just given birth to a
son she named aegon Targaryen Ned
secretly vowed to raise him and protect
him and did so by adopting him as his
own bastard son whom he renamed Jon Snow
meanwhile the Mad King decided to
destroy all of King's Landing rather
than surrender leading Jaime Lannister
to kill him earning the name kingslayer
the Mad King's pregnant wife though
escaped to safety but tragically Prince
rhaegar's wife Elia Martel and their two
children weren't so lucky murdered by
the mountain at the orders of Tywin
Lannister I'm going to hear you confess
before you die you raped my sister you
murdered her you killed her children
with the Mad King slain and his army
thoroughly beaten Robert Baratheon took
the throne he married Cersei Lannister
though he never stopped Mourning lyanna
she belonged with me
[Music]
Ned Stark returned home to Winterfell he
never told anyone the truth of John's
parentage letting even his own wife
believe he had betrayed her with another
woman and bittering her forever against
John as for the Mad King's wife while
she died giving birth to a daughter
named Daenerys who along with her older
brother viserys was smuggled across the
sea to essos in the hope that one day
they could return to Westeros to claim
their Throne by winning the Game of
Thrones
in 2016 more than 23 million people
watched each episode of Game of Thrones
eager to find out which intricate plots
would unfold on screen but did you know
some of the most interesting storylines
actually take place behind the scenes
let's take a closer spoiler-filled look
at the Untold Truth of Game of Thrones
Pop Quiz Hot Shots Author George R.R
Martin had long been reluctant to adapt
his novel series A Song of Ice and Fire
because he didn't want the on-screen
version to tarnish the Brilliance of his
books so when David benioff and DB wise
approached him for HBO Martin agreed on
one condition they had to answer one
question is there a way to get out of
the dungeon without using the wizard key
what the hell are you talking about
actually Martin asked them who they
believed Jon Snow's true parents were
when Benny off and Weiss gave the
correct answer Martin gave his Blessing
in return while the rest of the world
finally learned the truth during the
season six finale that Jon Snow is
really the son of rhaegar Targaryen and
lyanna Stark it's not hard to admire
bellyoff and wise for sussing out the
truth years ago HBO nearly canceled it
before its aired believe it or not even
after solving Martin's riddle benioff
and Weiss's first pass at the Pilot's
episode wasn't very good HBO Executives
and producers were so unhappy they
almost ended the show before I could
even begin
in an interview Davey wise explained
that after watching it one of the HBO
head honchos put it bluntly you guys
have a massive problem the script was
Rewritten about 90 of the pilot was
re-shot with a new director and the
showrunners also made major changes to
the cast the role of Daenerys Targaryen
was recast substituting Amelia Clarke
for actress Tams and Merchant Catelyn
Stark was recast too bringing in
Michelle Fairley for Jennifer ale the
original pilot has today never aired and
that's a shame for plenty of reasons
George R.R Martin explained that he had
a cameo during the narrus's wedding
scene it was sad to say left on The
Cutting Room floor I was a pentoshi
nobleman in the background wearing a
gigantic hat lady stoneheart if you're a
Game of Thrones fan who's never read the
books you might not realize that one of
the franchise's most popular characters
hasn't even shown up on screen yet in
the novels the Red Wedding isn't the end
of the story for doomed Catelyn Stark
after she's killed the phrase throw her
body into to the river where it flows
for three days before being recovered by
Barrack dondarian and the Brotherhood
without banners Lord Barrick magically
resurrects her at the cost of his own
life he dies as the spark of Life passes
to Lady Catelyn when she Rises her skin
is gray her hairs turned brittle and
white and her face is a massive shredded
wounds filled with clotted black blood
she cannot speak because the bloody
bastards cut her throat too deep for
that but she remembers Kathleen Stark is
dead and Lady stoneheart's Reign has
begun she becomes the new leader of the
Brotherhood and directs them in a bloody
campaign of Vengeance against Lannisters
and freys when learning Klingon just
isn't enough although Martin only
created a rudimentary outline for the
fictional languages of his novel Game of
Thrones producers required a much
broader vocabulary to use on the show
they turn to language creation Society
founder David J Peterson and he created
entire languages for both Dothraki and
Valerian including grammatical rules and
the pronunciation guides if you'd like
to learn either language yourself direct
your web browser to the appropriately
named dothraki.org the Red Wedding
really happened well the Red Wedding
sort of really happened Author George
R.R Martin frequently draws from Real
History for his books and a notably
nasty incident in Scottish history
served as inspiration for the infamous
red wedding in season three in a 15th
century incident that would be later
known as the black dinner William the 16
year old Earl of Douglas and his
ten-year-old brother were invited to a
feast with James II the child King of
Scotland the king's advisors dragged the
young Earl and his brothers outside the
castle gave them a mock trial and then
beheaded them both the Lannisters and
their regards similarly the purple
wedding where King Joffrey meets his
maker was based on a real incident too
the poisoning and death of England's
Prince Eustis at a feast in 1153
sometimes fans do the work while Martin
created a lush and vibrantly detailed
World In A Song of Ice and Fire he does
occasionally leave things out as a
result the showrunners sometimes have to
use their own imaginations or that of
others to fill in the gaps in one
prominent example from season six the
show's costumers were tasked with
creating a Sigil buckle for Howland Reed
to wear during the Tower of Joy
flashback scenes Martin had described it
in the books as an alligator-like lizard
lion but he never offered a complete
description luckily fans have been
creating artwork based on Martin's
vision for years the producers must have
been impressed with this image since it
sure looks like it was copied and pasted
right onto Reed's costume horsepower and
bodybuilding in season 6 during the
breathtaking cavalry charge at the
Battle of the bastards Jon Snow stands
alone on the battlefield as Ramsay
Bolton and umber Horsemen right toward
him at Breakneck speed but Snow's Army
suddenly rushes up behind him igniting
one of the show's most impressive battle
scenes if you thought it had to be green
screen trickery however you were wrong
the showrunners revealed in a behind the
scenes video that those were dozens of
real live horses charging Harrington at
full Gallop until the the last minute I
was stood there facing off against this
cavalry charge which is really scary
we're a bit annoyed because I think
everyone's going to think it was CGI and
it wasn't so now we know about the
horses but how did producers create that
impressive pile of bodies on the
battlefield during the battle the video
reveals that all the bodies were
actually life-size dummies not
computer-generated fakery the crew
acquired hundreds of mannequins dressed
them in appropriate House Umber and
house bolt and armor then coated them in
mud and fake blood and piled them in a
gigantic Heap even the dead horses among
the men are dummies equipped with
saddles now that's attention to detail
happy ending for lady one of the most
heartbreaking moments on Game of Thrones
came during season one when Prince
Joffrey orders the death of Arya Stark's
beloved direwolf when the Lannister
soldiers can't locate Aya's pets Queen
Cersei orders that sansa's direwolf lady
be killed instead thankfully lady or
rather the Northern Inuit dog that
played her on screen got a happier
ending in real life actress Sophie
Turner band it with the animal during
the shoot and she adopted her more than
meets the eye in A Song of Ice and Fire
Daenerys Targaryen and her brother
viserys have purple eyes and Game of
Thrones showrunners planned for them to
have them on the show as well
unfortunately the purple contacts
affected actress Emilia Clarke so badly
that producers decided to ditch their
contacts and reshoot the scenes with her
natural baby blues and that's not the
only eye-opening tale from the set Arya
Stark is blinded during her training
with the Faceless Men and in order to
accurately portray the role actress Macy
Williams wore completely opaque 16
millimeter thick contact lenses for her
speaking scenes and a pair with only a
pinhole in the center during fight
scenes a gift for hate until Ramsay Snow
hit the screen during season three
Joffrey Baratheon was perhaps the most
universally despised character on the
show which I disagree with he was the
best character by far Irish actor Jack
Gleason did such a convincing job as a
sadistic boy King that Martin reportedly
sent him a note that read
congratulations on your marvelous
performance everyone hates you
oh gee thanks George
casting can make or break a show and
that's particularly true when it's based
on a popular book series when it comes
to the Beloved Game of Thrones on HBO
many of the characters don't quite match
what's written in George R.R Martin's
books in fact in a few circumstances
they don't match at all here's how the
cast of Game of Thrones should really
look Yara Greyjoy the producers of Game
of Thrones changed asha greyjoy's name
to Yara on the show maybe to avoid
confusion with OSHA the wildling but her
name isn't all that's been changed the
novel says she's got black hair cut
short and that her nose was too big and
too sharp for her thin face but her
smile made up for it Yara doesn't do
much smiling on the show of course but
then with a brother-like Theon you
wouldn't smile either speaking of Theon
Greyjoy after he was tortured as the
prisoner of Ramsay Bolton Theon Greyjoy
emerged from his ordeal mostly unscathed
well except for his dangly bits next
time you think about making naked girls
but in the books Theon was apparently
treated much more harshly with him
getting a gaunt skeletal appearance as a
result the trauma of his captivity also
turned his hair white making him look
practically like an old man of course
Theon was probably not so concerned
about his hair by the time he escaped
Ramsay
Ramsay Bolton on the show Ramsay is a
really ugly person but mostly because of
his heinous acts like the aforementioned
torture and wiener cunning of Theon
Greyjoy or when he kills his own Daddy
but in the books Martin wrote him as a
real Ugo he wrote he remained an ugly
man big boned and sloped shouldered with
a fleshiness to him that suggested that
in later life he would run to Fat his
skin was pink and blotchy his nose broad
his mouth small his hair long and dark
and dry his lips were wide and Meaty but
the thing men noticed first about him
were his eyes small close set queerly
pale his eyes were all but colorless
like two chips of dirty ice all dirty
eye size that's what we'll call him and
does anyone else think that shaggy
haircut kind of makes him look like
Glenn Danzig
Brienne of Tarth part of brienne's
tragedy is how much he wants to fall in
love and be loved but she knows she's
painfully awkward and ugly by westerosi
standards of course because this is
television the showrunners cast the
beautiful and statuesque Gwendolyn
Christie for the part so she'll never
actually be the homely butt kicker
described in the books meanwhile
throughout the course of the novels
Brienne has run-ins with enemies that
leave her even more damaged like when
she got her teeth knocked out
Martin wrote that brienne's hair was a
squirrel's nest of dirty straw and that
her eyes were very large and very blue
meanwhile her features were Broad and
coarse her teeth prominent and crooked
her mouth too wide her lips so plump
they seemed swollen a thousand freckles
speckled her cheeks and brow and her
nose had been broken more than once
sander the Hound Clegane HBO's makeup
artist did a great job covering the mass
of scars and twisted flesh that cover
one side of standard clegane's face it's
pretty much perfect except for one
little thing they got the wrong side of
his face the book says that the left
side of his face was a ruin his ear had
been burned away there was nothing but a
hole down by his jaw you could see a
hint of bone where the flesh had been
seared away aside from the ear and the
Bony jaw situation the Hound looks
pretty incredible but it makes you
wonder what made them flip sides like
that maybe actor Rory McCann just
doesn't like that side of his face
Dario Naharis it's not too hard to
figure out why the show's producers mix
things up for their take on Dario
Naharis that's because Dario should have
looked less like a badass Warrior and
more like a reject from The Hunger Games
the novels describe Dario as flamboyant
with a beard that was cut into three
prongs and dyed blue the same color as
his eyes and the curly hair that fell to
his collar his pointed mustachios were
painted gold no wonder Daenerys fell for
the old gold Mustachio charmer he
probably picked up his style tips from
the legendary mystery the pickup artist
meeting mystery it was almost like a
love at first sight
with a cowboy hat and his Medallion
necklace
I was like this guy is smoking balls
tonight Tyrion Lannister Peter Dinklage
is just about perfect as Tyrion
Lannister better known as the Imp but
there's just one problem and at this
point you can probably guess what it is
that's right he's just not ugly enough
noticing a trend here the books describe
him as having a squashed in face then
after the events of the battle of the
Blackwater he lost about half of his
nose and finally he has different
colored eyes so yeah Jorah Mormont don't
look so surprised but sir Jorah in the
books is not quite as handsome as the
showrunners would have us believe our
favorite friend zone Knight is more
attractive and also more lightly built
on the Game of Thrones television series
than his book version counterpart once
again Martin plainly states that this
character isn't going to win any beauty
contests sergora was not a handsome man
he had a neck and shoulders like a bull
and coarse black hair covered his arms
and chest so thickly that there was none
left for his head ish kind of looks like
a medieval version of like Clint Howard
or Bob Balaban or even Wallace Shawn
he'd make a good Jorah right
inconceivable yeah you're probably right
never mind
some of the most familiar faces in
Westeros have changed a lot during the
course of Game of Thrones run on HBO
over the course of the series several of
the show's key actors have ended up
being replaced leading fans to wonder
just what really happened
throughout the entire series Emilia
Clarke has shined as Daenerys Targaryen
from a mild Young Bride to the Fierce
and ruthless Warrior she is today
Daenerys has been through one of the
show's most exciting arcs and without
Clark's portrayal far fewer viewers
would have fallen in love with the
character the way that they have hailed
as a feminist icon fans have been
gripped by daenerys's finest moments and
Clark herself has achieved International
recognition for the role as well as
nominations for several Awards
I'm not going to stop the wheel
I'm going to break the wheel
with that in mind it might seem
difficult to believe that anyone else
ever could have played Daenerys but in
the initially troubled pilot for Game of
Thrones Daenerys was originally played
by tamzin Merchant best known for her
role as Henry VIII's fifth wife
Catherine Howard on the Tudors creators
David benioff and DB Weiss have been
open about their disdain for the
original pilot but neither the two
showrunners nor casting director Nina
Gold have fully discussed the reason for
Merchant's exit today fans are left to
wonder just how different the series
might have been with a different
Daenerys riding those dragons
game of thrones's third season
introduced a new potential love interest
for Daenerys in the form of Dario
Naharis played by Ed skrine this clever
long-haired mercenary was obviously
interested in Daenerys from day one and
when he betrayed his own men to join her
side it became clear that Dario's Maka
nations would make him an even bigger
player in the seasons to come after a
three-episode Arc in the third season
however skrine was unceremoniously
replaced by Mikhail Hausman as it turned
out skrine had run into a scheduling
issue as he was set to appear in the new
transporter film the actor has since
admitted that it wasn't the easiest
decision but that he had no regrets in
leaving Game of Thrones luckily for
housemen he quickly became yet another
one of the show's beloved key players
and his romance with Daenerys left many
wondering where he might end up as the
show concludes in the early seasons of
Game of Thrones viewers discovered that
Cersei Lannister's three children all of
whom were supposedly of Baratheon blood
were actually bastards born of her
incestuous affair with her twin brother
Jaime however nobody paid much attention
to to any of the children besides
Joffrey cersei's eldest and most wicked
child who eventually ascended to the
throne and wreaked a significant amount
of havoc on King's Landing in Westeros
as a whole as a result the other two
supposed Baratheon children were often
shunted to the side making it easy for
them to be recast as required a frequent
reality when dealing with young actors
whose growth easily put them out of sync
with the show's pacing because of these
age issues Tom and Baratheon was recast
in the show's fourth season and when it
was time for him to take the crown from
Joffrey Calum weary was replaced by Dean
Charles Chapman Chapman went on to
handle many of the mild King tommen's
more difficult scenes including a love
scene with his new wife Marjorie Tyrell
as well as his death at the end of the
sixth season however many fans might
have recognized Chapman's face from
somewhere since he had actually appeared
in the show's third season playing a
young Lannister Squire who was held
hostage by the Starks and eventually
killed by Rickard karstark this actually
gives Chapman a rare distinction of
having played two separate roles during
the show's run and having died twice too
much like Tom and Cersei Lannister's
middle child Marcella went largely
overlooked until later seasons of
Thrones Marcella was essentially left
out of the plot entirely until the
second season when her uncle Tyrion
decided to send her to Dorne creating a
permanent Rift between Tyrion and Cersei
in the fifth season she reappeared as a
Love Struck teenager engaged to Tristan
Martell the young prince of Dorne thanks
to an ongoing battle between the
Lannister and Martel families she ended
up murdered at the hands of ellaria sand
shortly after she discovered her true
parentage though Marcella was played by
the young actress Amy Richardson during
her appearances in the early Seasons
when she returned she was played by the
dynamic Nell tiger free much like Tom
and strategic recasting this can likely
be chalked up to discrepancies between
the growth of the actor and her
character as the older of the
much-feared Clegane Brothers the
mountain is one of westerosa's most
terrifying Warriors and although he has
kinda managed to make it through the
entire Series so far are he has
nonetheless undergone a significant
transformation along the way once a
formidable fighter known for his
penchant for committing war crimes on
behalf of the Lannisters the mountain
was nearly felled by a poisoned spear
tip during his duel with Oberyn Martell
in season four after that however he was
turned into a kind of mute zombie loyal
only to Cersei herself but that wasn't
the only transformation that the
mountain has undergone during Game of
Thrones run as he's actually been played
by no fewer than three separate actors
in season one when the mountain nearly
killed Loris Tyrell after a joust he was
played by Conan Stevens an Australian
actor the mountain was far less visible
in season two but when he did appear he
was played by the Welsh actor Ian white
from the fourth season on the Fearsome
and intimidating Icelandic strongman
half Thor Euless bjornsson has portrayed
the mountain of course now that he's in
sconced in an Iron Mask it doesn't seem
to matter much that this massive man has
changed faces three times the tarly
family isn't exactly the most important
clan in Westeros but astute viewers will
have gotten to know them pretty well
over the years by far the most
significant member of the family is
Samwell tarly The Lovable Bookworm of
the Night's Watch and frequent companion
to Jon Snow Sam has proven to be the
heart and soul of the show time and time
again but he's not so popular among his
own family in the sixth season when Sam
arrived at horn Hill with his girlfriend
Gilly he received a cold welcome from
his Stern father Randall who clearly
favors Sam's handsome and accomplished
brother dickon
not fat enough already
during season six Freddie stroma of
Harry Potter Fame appeared as dickon
however scheduling issues forced him out
of the show so Black Sails Tom Hopper
stepped in to plenty of Acclaim from
fans sadly Hopper's time as dickon has
also been cut short as both he and his
father Randall were burned alive by
Daenerys when they refused to bend the
knee to her in season seven easy come
easy go
most viewers of the show will be
familiar with Stannis Baratheon who as
King Robert baratheon's brother
staunchly believed he was the rightful
heir to the iron throne but some might
not remember his wife Sally speratheon
while Stanis fought for the throne with
the aid of Melisandre Sally's remained
nothing if not loyal after all she stuck
by her husband through several
unsuccessful battles as well as his
obvious attraction to Melisandre herself
when Stannis used their daughter Shireen
as a human sacrifice Sally's finally
took her own life only for Stannis to
meet his final defeat in battle a few
hours later
Sully's when she was introduced was a
very minor character who can be spotted
simply standing in the vicinity of
Melisandre and Stannis while the latter
commits himself to the Lord of Light
during a magical ceremony in the second
season's Premiere at that time she was
played by Sarah McKeever had no lines at
all and served as little more than a
glorified extra however when Sully's
role was expanded to include a
multi-episode Arc the show chose a more
venerated actress for the role Tara
Fitzgerald who famously appeared
opposite Ray finds in Hamlet on Broadway
during the mid-1990s
Game of Thrones first episode ended on a
pretty shocking final scene specifically
the young Bran Stark being pushed out of
a tall tower after catching Jaime and
Cersei in a compromising position bran
survived the fall however losing his
mobility and eventually gaining a new
set of powers including the ability to
review and even meddle in events of the
very distant past making him The Heir
Apparent to the role of the three-eyed
Raven when the audience finally met the
mysterious three-eyed Raven in season
four he looked fairly different to the
character fans would later come to know
originally played by strewn Roger Brand
first meets The Raven while the
omniscient being is holed up in a
secluded Tree by the time the three-eyed
Raven returned to the show in its sixth
season Roger had been replaced by
legendary actor Max voncito best known
for The Exorcist in Flash Gordon since
then it has been voncito's Raven who has
guided bran through the secrets of the
past present and future of Westeros Game
of Thrones is Rife with villains and
antagonists but few are more Sinister or
more mysterious than the night King the
ancient and seemingly infallible leader
of the white walkers the Walkers who
reside far north of a wall that
separates Westeros from the northern
Wilderness were previously considered
nothing more than a frightening Legend
but have recently made their presence
known in Westeros in a pretty
spectacular way throughout the show's
run audiences have watched the night
King perform a range of Despicable acts
from turning a child's sacrifice into a
white walker to taking down one of
daenerys's beloved dragons though the
character comes to life via impressive
prosthetic makeup as the show went on
sharp-eyed viewers realized that the
night King looked a little different
from when we first met him before season
six the night King was played by Richard
Blake but the role then went to Vladimir
furtick an actor hailing from Slovakia
though the show's creators have never
provided a concrete reason for the
change it's possible that furtic won the
role thanks to his history as a stunt
man giving him more Mobility for battle
scene
throughout thrones's run Barrick
dundarian has quite literally lived
several lives in season one he served as
nothing more than a member of a search
party sent by Ned Stark to bring the
mountain to justice as war broke out in
Westeros however he joined a group
called the Brotherhood without banners
who threw their loyalty to the Lord of
Light have followed Barrick as he is
constantly revived from the dead by his
resident Red Priest thoros of Mir most
recently Barrack has been found aiding
Jon Snow in his fight against the White
Walkers traveling north of the wall in
order to get more information on these
mysterious and ancient creatures David
Michael Scott portrayed Barrick for his
minor role during the first season
beginning in season three however Irish
actor Richard Dormer took the reins
luckily Barracks change in appearance is
easy enough to explain in Universe
considering the man died multiple times
off screen before viewers met him for
the second time again
after an uneven final season comprised
of only six episodes fans were excited
concerned and downright desperate to see
how the Game of Thrones Saga would
finally end from the Iron Throne to the
fate of Westeros and the final showdown
between Daenerys and Jon Snow here's
what the ending of Game of Thrones means
not just for the final season but for
the entire series beware spoilers are
coming
after the burning of King's Landing in
the previous episode several main
characters wander through the brutal
aftermath with Tyrion Lannister the hand
of the queen looking stricken as he
walks down ruined streets and sees the
bodies of those Daenerys burned without
Mercy as he and Jon Snow surveyed their
destruction John and Tyrion separately
set off to meet the queen John's Journey
finds him at odds with gray worm over
the execution of Lannister soldiers but
soon after Tyrion sets off on his own he
makes a horrifying Discovery in a truly
heartbreaking moment Tyrion finds the
bodies of his brother and sister and
breaks down amid the rubble with the
rest of his house literally entombed
Tyrion finds himself suddenly alone and
in that moment his resolve to defy his
Queen strengthens later as the Dothraki
and unsullied celebrate their Victory
Daenerys makes a grand entrance riding
atop drogon and landing in a perfect
shot with her silhouetted by his wings
while she gives a full-throated victory
speech in which she Praises her Army for
taking down a tyrant and claiming the
city as their own viewers know the truth
Danny is no better than the Tyrant she
aims to replace in fact she's probably a
lot worse as she announces her plans to
prolong the war and conquer the rest of
the world Daenerys has always bent
toward justice but with this
Proclamation it seems as if she's
finally gone too far and even her most
trusted advisor seemed frightened by her
endless hunger for power
in the aftermath of The Siege on King's
Landing during which Tyrion begged his
Queen to show Mercy to those who
couldn't defend themselves it seems as
if the last remaining Lannister could no
longer bring himself to follow Daenerys
and has seen her for what she really is
or at least what she's ultimately become
Daenerys is already furious with Tyrion
after finding out that he freed Jaime
which ultimately doesn't even matter
considering that Jaime and Cersei are
both dead but Tyrion has his own
grievances with the Mother of Dragons as
they confront each other atop a ruined
King's Landing he admits that he freed
his brother but reminds her that she
decimated an entire city moments later
he tosses aside the badge that
identifies him as the hand of the queen
Daenerys immediately has him arrested
but his point is made marking yet
another advisor who leaves her side when
she needs them the most her
transformation into a new version of her
father the Mad King who killed anyone
who displeased him is complete as Tyrion
sits in captivity awaiting his certain
execution he's visited by a visibly torn
Jon Snow who despite his allegiance to
Daenerys still obviously trust tyrion's
counsel John defends Daenerys at first
saying that though he can't condone what
happened the war is finally over but
Tyrion persists reminding Jon that
Daenerys isn't even close to finished
and the only way she can achieve her
ultimate goal is through even more death
and destruction on a global scale Tyrion
also reminds Jon that he once had the
power to do what Daenerys did
specifically to ride atop a dragon and
destroy an entire city and he never
would before she sacked King's Landing
daenerys's destruction often seemed
entirely righteous like when she freed
slaves and killed their masters but as
Tyrion points out the murder of
countless innocent men women and
children can't possibly be defended and
at this point the dragon Queen will stop
at nothing to achieve her goals though
Tyrion recognizes that love is more
powerful than reason he still does
everything in his power to convince Jon
of the path ahead you've tried to
protect people
who is the greatest threat to the people
now
John the true heir to the throne having
received wise counsel from the hand
knows that there's only one move left to
finally end the war once and for all
John finds Daenerys in the throne room
admiring the throne she's worked so hard
to win as he asks her why she murdered
children in the streets of the Capitol
she tries to entice him with her vision
of the new world the two of them can
build together as they Embrace John
proclaims that Daenerys will always be
his Queen just when it seems like all
hope for peace is lost he stabs her
holding her and weeping this is the
moment the series has been building
towards since the beginning Ned Stark
lost his head for being too Honorable in
the end Jon Snow betrayed his honor in
order to save it he made the impossible
Choice killing his lover and queen to
whom he'd pledged his eternal loyalty
for the greater good of his family and
the world
after Jon becomes the queen Slayer all
is silent for a moment until drogon
reappears coming face to face with Jon
in a frightening moment when it seems
like the last remaining Targaryen might
immediately face Justice for killing the
Mother of Dragons however drogon's
anguish over the death of his mother is
directed not at John but it's something
entirely different specifically the Iron
Throne which he torches into a melted
pile of slag in a stream of fire the
ultimate symbol of power in Westeros is
completely destroyed Daenerys has always
referred to her dragons as her children
and her final moments with drogon are
heartfelt as he tries to nudge her awake
and screams in pain for his lost Mother
after demolishing the throne once and
for all drogon gently lifts Daenerys off
the ground and flies away with her
safely ensconced in his claws making for
a fitting end to daenerys's Arc she was
reborn with all three of her dragons and
even in death she remains a part of her
only remaining child moreover drogon
identifies dany's true Killer without
uttering Arena work it wasn't Jon who
was responsible for the end of her life
instead it was her unending quest to
seek the Iron Throne itself it's like
Cersei said way back in season one when
you play the game of thrones you win
will you die
there is no middle ground
since the beginning the throne is
represented death it was composed of the
weapons of the king's enemies and men
and women fought and killed for a chance
to sit on it Daenerys always wanted to
break the wheel now the drogon has
destroyed the Iron Throne the wheel and
Westeros has finally been broken weeks
after daenerys's death Tyrion is Led out
of his cell to face a new Council made
up of familiar characters alongside a
few faces who have been absent from the
show for several seasons the unsullied
have taken King's Landing and are
holding John and Tyrion captive and
Tyrion must not only argue his case
against gray Worm but for the entire
Council but before tyrion's fate can be
decided the Lords and Ladies of Westeros
must choose a new monarch as a group
debates who should rule next Tyrion has
asked whether or not he wants the job he
describes himself as the worst possible
choice and no one really argues his
points in order to explain who he does
have in mind however Tyrion Begins by
telling the assembled that what unites
everybody is the power of a story then
identifying the person he says has the
best story Bran Stark who has journeyed
beyond the wall and back to become the
All-Seeing three-eyed Raven everybody
seems a bit stunned by this unexpected
nomination except for bran but now that
he's the three-eyed Raven looking
surprised isn't really his thing but
once Tyrion points out that because bran
can't have children the leader of
Westeros will be chosen rather than
receive it by Birthright he receives a
unanimous vote after everything the
Starks have lived through the eldest
surviving Stark son is named Bran the
broken first of his name in exchange
bran chooses Tyrion as his new hand
bringing his Arc to a fitting conclusion
as far as his own arc is concerned
Bran's Ascension to the throne may seem
surprising given the path his story has
taken throughout the series moreover in
this final season bran doesn't actually
do much aside from glauer at other
characters from his chair and say weird
things but if you remember the very
first episode of the series bran has a
front row seat to an execution carried
out by his father the scene is meant as
a lesson for bran and the rules of
Justice and Leadership namely that Duty
and honor justifies violence and death
but now that bran will take over as king
of Westeros in the wake of daenerys's
war crimes it seems like a sure bet that
he'll have taken his father's lesson and
will apply the inverse Mercy fairness
and Justice Trump Duty and honor and are
the only true path to peace and life
since the beginning of the Season Sansa
who has established herself as a Fair
leader as well as a sharp and shrewd
strategist has bristled at the thought
of the north falling under anyone's rule
throughout Daenerys Reign she argued for
the north to maintain its status as an
independent territory with its own
monarchs and wardens when John told her
about his true parentage she immediately
shared the information with Tyrion
clearly hoping to keep control of the
north by not only keeping a tyrant from
taking the throne but by putting a half
Stark Regent in power while that plan
didn't pan out Sansa ultimately made
sure the north was taken care of during
the council meeting Sansa is hesitant to
cast a vote in favor of bran and as she
turns to her brother and tells him that
she loves him and that she's sure he'll
be a great king she insists that the
north remain its own territory and bran
grants her request thanks to Sansa the
north can keep its identity and its
independence and since the north always
remembers its citizens will certainly
remember what the lady of Winterfell did
to protect them as for the rest of the
characters each of them is seen off
properly with arcs completed stories
told and Journeys finally finished gray
worm sets off for Noth alone still
smarting after losing both missande and
his Queen Braun returns to claim his
lordship of high garden and becomes
master of coin and Brands Administration
flanked by a small Council that includes
Brienne Davos Sam and Tyrion Podrick
Payne now Brand's attendant has been
knighted and made a member of the King's
Guard since viewers last saw him not
only are several stories completed but
some characters write out stories of
their own making sure the people they
lost won't be forgotten after finding
Jaime's unfinished entry in the book
listing westerosi Knights Brienne
completes it herself capping It Off by
writing died protecting his Queen
meanwhile Sam presents the council with
a book written by one of the maesters
called what else A Song of Ice and Fire
in an obvious and rather heavy-handed
reference to the book series by George
R.R Martin on which the series is based
unlike Martin's series however this book
appears to to be finished John for
murdering the queen is banished back
into the Night's Watch a symbolic move
and the only way the council can seem to
broker peace with the unsullied and get
them to relinquish their hold on the
city Upon returning to Castle black John
reunites with torment as well as a large
group of wildlings and his direwolf
ghost who despite missing an ear is
thrilled to see his master once again
in the end the series closes with shots
of the family with which it began the
Starks who have scattered to various
corners of Westeros and Beyond Sansa is
coronated at Winterfell proudly taking
her seat as the citizens of the north
raised their swords and cheer for the
new Queen in the north Arya boards a
ship headed for the unknown lands west
of Westeros sailing under the Stark
Banner on a quest to learn what lies
beyond the part of the world where their
Maps end meanwhile Jon sets out from
Castle black with tormund ghost and a
group of wildlings in tow as they begin
their Journey to the far north some
green growth can be seen peeking out
from underneath the thick layers of snow
throughout game of thrones's run
audiences have always been told that
winter is coming but now that the night
King is no more and a new age has begun
in Westeros it seems as if the show's
Long Winter May finally be coming to an
end
Game of Thrones has always been a pretty
sprawling TV show and plenty of material
has ended up on The Cutting Room floor
but though these scenes were deleted
they're still fascinating to explore
especially since these moments could
have subtly changed the course of the
story or at least our perception of
events let's explore some of the more
substantial moments I'd never made at
the final cut the execution of
Littlefinger was one of the most
shocking moments in the season 7 finale
but how did Sansa and Arya Stark come to
learn about his whole lifetime of crimes
in an interview with variety actor Isaac
Hempstead Rai 2 portrays Bran Stark
revealed that he shot a deleted sequence
of Sophie Turner who portrays Sansa in
the scene Sansa reportedly consulted
with bran just ahead of littlefinger's
trial as you may recall Santa was
convinced her sister Arya was out to
assassinate her in order to become the
lady of Winterfell Arya suspect did the
same of Sansa and it was all thanks to
that master manipulator Littlefinger
viewers were sweating buckets watching
the season 7 finale since it looked like
one of the Stark's sisters might kill
the other but then Sansa and Arya
flipped the script sends saying
Littlefinger to death revealing their
Feud to be an elaborate ruse thank you
for all your many lessons Lord Baelish
it was a big twist but it seemed to
leave a bit of a plot hole behind too
how will the star children suddenly so
certain of littlefinger's history of
manipulation and betrayal according to
Hempstead Wright a deleted scene from
the episode would have cleared up any
ambiguity it revealed exactly how the
Stark sisters learned of Littlefinger
schemes and it would have led audiences
see how Sansa and Arya arrived at the
decision to execute him in the deleted
scene bran uses his Newfound abilities
as a three-eyed Raven to peer into
littlefingers past and earthing every
underhanded thing had ever done in his
quest for power Hamstead Wright told
variety the story was that it suddenly
occurred to Sansa that she had a huge
CCTV department at a discretion and it
might be a good idea to check with bran
first before she cuts her own sister
though audiences can kind of still fill
in the blanks without the scene its
inclusion would have threaded the plot
together with a little more clarity it
also would have shed more light on
Brands and men's Powers giving us a much
stronger impression of how extraordinary
his gifts really are Bran's ability to
access the history of man and the
secrets of Westeros is an astonishing
scale and the potentially powerful
weapon as was made clear in season 8
Brands knowledge that John is a rightful
heir to the Seven Kingdoms Spartan and
fortunate chain of events one that's
played an important part in Daenerys
targaryens descend into madness Sansa is
undergone a remarkable transformation
since we first met a dreamy young girl
looking forward to marriage and one
person who's had a major hand in her
development is sandor Clegane otherwise
known as the Hound throughout much of
Game of Thrones he seemed ultimately
drawn to and repulsed by sansa's
innocence frequently calling her little
bird with a mixture of sweetness and
condescension
you of course the Hound uses that
nickname again in the fourth episode of
Season 8 when the Dynamics between the
two are remarkably different it's a
scene that highlights just how much
Sansa has grown throughout the course of
Game of Thrones
you've changed little bird yet one
deleted scene all the way back in season
two depicts a Sansa who's already
prepared to stand up to the Hound
I don't know any songs
not anymore instead of a quivering wave
we see a young woman who's perfectly
willing to stand her ground and perhaps
that was a problem the scene of her
standing up for herself even a little
bit could have been seen as too much too
soon as far as sansa's development is
concerned Sansa and the hounds season 8
reunion certainly wouldn't have been
half as Bittersweet if she'd already
demonstrated the potential for such
strength away back in season two
tormund has always been right at the
center of the tension between the
Night's Watch and the wildlings he's
helpful to the Night's Watch but he's
not sentimental about their history he's
committed to being part of the free folk
but he's also Jon Snow's friend when
John was the commander of the Night's
Watch he welcomed tormund and other
wildlings across the wall that brought
attention to its boiling point resulting
in the slaying of Jon Snow in a deleted
scene from season 5 that would have
taken place before Jon's death and
Resurrection sir Alice a Thorne one of
Snow's eventual Killers verbally spars
with tormund he lets tormund know just
how much he distrusts him and how little
he likes housing him tormund roughly
replies he must no longer be in charge
then it's a moment of intense
foreshadowing but had the scene been
included in the show it might have made
tormund seem partially responsible for
Jon Snow's murder however involuntarily
though he didn't wield a dagger his
aggressive needling of Alistair might
have been perceived as a straw that
broke the camel's back audiences might
have blamed tormund for sir Alice's
subsequent actions though the scene is
appropriate for that era of the show it
may well of Caster Paul over an alliance
that has since helped shape the future
of Westeros
Game of Thrones Minds conflict from
absolutely every angle life against
death woman against man religion against
cynicism another major Clash the ongoing
animosity between the nobility and
common folk of Westeros The Prostitute
Shea had a pretty long run on Game of
Thrones but her luck eventually run out
first there was her damaging testimony
against Tyrion Lannister who then
tragically killed her when he
encountered her in his father's bed it
was tragic and it was extreme Bertha
deleted scene between Shay and Braun
reveals a far more tender side to the
conflict and it might change how you
view Shay's actions in the scene bran
commiserates with shea as a fellow
commoner these people even the good ones
who use this as their police
and when we're no longer in use they
spit us out it's the kindest we've ever
seen bran and the moment emphasizes the
difficult position that Shay was in we
have to adapt to circumstances is what
I'm saying learn some new tricks with
this scene in mind what happens between
Shea and Tyrion becomes even more
complicated yes she does something awful
but this scene dares to ask what choice
did she have
Grand maester py cell was always a
conniving man even when acting like a
daughtering old fool he delighted in
playing passive aggressive games and he
never missed an opportunity to dismiss
and disrespect Tyrion Batista testable
nature often went completely unnoticed
by other characters on Game of Thrones
it even went unnoticed by many people
watching the show Bertha deleted scene
between pyth cell and Tywin Lannister
would have changed that Dynamic
enormously pycel interrupts Tywin while
he's fishing and as usual he's playing
the fall in order to seem
non-threatening and inept unimpressed by
the charade Tywin cuts off by sells
babbling
am I the only one to see through this
performance this certainly changes the
dynamic between pie cell and Taiwan it
also suggests that most of the other
people in King's Landing are comparably
Daft the scene doesn't just make Tywin
seem more formidable it also changes how
we see pycel now he seems like a
dangerous and devious man instead of a
mild annoyance
in the second season of Game of Thrones
Daenerys learns an important lesson in
trust after she's ferociously betrayed
by a handmaiden Daria
he said you'd never leave Kath alive
Carmen Daria meets a wholly and
fortunate end with Daenerys sealing her
inside a vault to die which is an
arguably kind of a harsh way to take
somebody out as it turns out we didn't
even see the worst of doria's actions in
a deleted scene from season 2 she
gleefully strangles daenerys's
handmaiden Eerie to death of course that
scene effectively turns Doria into a far
more Insidious character and it makes
her betrayal seem so much worse than
what we ever saw on screen
the white walkers were always a major
threat in Game of Thrones but it was
also a major challenge to get the people
of Westeros to believe the threat was
real Jon Snow spent an enormous chunk of
screen time arguing about the Walkers
though few people were ever willing to
take his warnings or Brand's Visions to
hurt good boy claims to have seen dead
men on the March Beyond the Wall thanks
to the magical help of a raven with
three eyes as it is a bit much but in a
deleted season two scene that we never
got to see it's revealed that Tywin
Lannister took the white walkers quite
seriously from early on after hearing
stories of corpses with blue eyes on
their bone white Masters Tywin discusses
setting an Envoy to Mance Raider and
then the king Beyond the Wall this plot
development would have seriously changed
their perception of Tywin and it would
have considerably raised the stakes for
the Lannisters as a whole had the scene
aired we would have seen the first major
house star preparing for battle with the
white walkers far ahead of time while
pretty much everyone else was too busy
being skeptical renley's death was a
linchpin of several plot threads
melisandre's dark and complex magic the
Tyrone those insatiable thirsts for
power and the war of the five Kings
Renly had the charm and Charisma that
Stannis lacked he had the backing of a
large and fruitful house and Brilliant
women like Marjorie at his side at this
point it's all too easy to forget what a
genuine threat he was but above and
beyond that Randy was loris's lover and
the deleted scene from season 2
illustrates their love of their
tenderness that's rather unusual for the
world of Game of Thrones in the scene
Loris laments is an ability to stop
renley's murder confiding in his sister
Marjorie that he feels somewhat
responsible for his Lover's death
[ __ ]
Marjorie
urges lores to turn his attention to
their family
whoa this scene makes the tyrell's
emotional Stakes all the more clear it's
easy to see Marjorie as conniving above
all else but this unusually touching
moment illustrates that she still very
much loves her brother
olena Tyrell was one of the most
fearsome characters in Game of Thrones a
brilliant strategist a cynical plutter
and the devoted grandmother she was a
woman who'd do anything to protect her
family and their interests case in point
her murder of Joffrey Baratheon at his
wedding in a deleted scene from season
six she discusses the Lannisters with
her son Mace Tyrell after mace has made
cersei's master of coin he's evidently
unable to see how it's being manipulated
but Elena sees exactly what's going on
and she's determined to keep Loris and
Marjorie as safe as possible Cersei
Lannister sent you to Bravos to get you
out of her way
and she sent the bloody King's Guard to
make certain you stayed there the scene
brings to light exactly how close
cersei's plan came to ending in failure
and how enormously the tyrells would go
on to lose in season seven and thus how
powerful Cersei truly is but the last
season of the series though forces were
arrayed on both the Tyrell and Lannister
sides it all came down to a game of wits
between the queen of Westeros and the
queen of thorns
the direwolves have always been more
than pets their Fates are foreshadowed
and influenced the face of the Stark
children from the very beginning from
ladies death and sansa's subsequent
suffering to greywind's mutilation and
Rob's murder at the Red Wedding in a
deleted scene from season 7 John gives
ghosts an important task before he sets
off to meet Daenerys keeps Sansa safe
ghost is essentially the only
sarkodirewolf left yes there's still
nymeria but that's the story for another
day the fact that Jon entrusted this job
to ghost as a sign of just How Deeply he
cares for Sansa it also emphasizes how
important Sansa Arya Jon and bran are to
each other their strong Alliance has
survived that of the Lannisters the
tyrells and the targaryens ghost is a
part of John or at least he used to be
before the king in the north open
ditched him in season eight you really
do Know Nothing Jon Snow
since it premiered on HBO in the spring
of 2011. Game of Thrones has become a
worldwide smash many stars of the show
have skyrocketed to fame but over the
course of making the series they've also
encountered some unexpected hardships
here's a look at some scary tricky and
grueling sacrifices actors had to make
for Game of Thrones
in her years of playing Sansa Stark
Sophie Turner has endured arranged
marriages sexual violence and the loss
of loved ones though Sansa began the
show as a spoiled child who wanted
nothing more than to be a princess she
has grown into a shrewd Warrior Turner
hasn't personally been through the
horrors that Sansa has but she's endured
her fair share of difficulties including
an unhygienic request after Sansa
escaped from King's Landing Turner was
asked to stop washing her hair so she
would look as disheveled as possible
during sansa's darkest times it wasn't
an enjoyable experience for Turner she
said it was really disgusting now I wear
a wig so I can wash my hair whenever I
want which is nice but yes for a couple
of years I was living with pretty greasy
hair
one of the show's all-time hardest
scenes to watch has to be the Red
Wedding near the end of the third season
Rob Stark betrays his promise to marry
the daughter of one of his allies Walter
Frey so the phrase Slaughter Rob his
pregnant bride to Lisa and his mother
Catlett none of the actors involved in
the Red Wedding were particularly
excited about filming the sequence but
una Chaplin who played Delisa had it
really bad after her pregnant character
is repeatedly stabbed in the stomach
she's left on the floor to torment Rob
chaplain spent hours lying on a floor in
a cold Belfast Studio she was freezing
and covered in fake blood while she
waited for the rest of the cast to
finish their scenes Chaplin's commitment
can't be understated
in the seventh season of Game of Thrones
several characters who hadn't yet met
came together with varying results when
Daenerys Targaryen met Jaime Lannister
for the first time it didn't go very
well during their battle Braun Jamie's
right hand man must operate an enormous
spear launcher to fight against
daenerys's Dragon drogon though Braun
does get one good hit in Against drogon
the Machine is quickly burned to ashes
bronze survives but gets caught in the
Flames drogon spends most of the scene
setting fire to the battlefield all the
actors had to contend with smoke
inhalation but Jerome Flynn who plays
Braun got the worst of it Director of
Photography Robert McLaughlin burned
diesel oil for dramatic black smoke most
of the crew wore masks Flynn had to go
unmasked and it's hard to miss the
discomfort visible on his face
the battle of the bastards which took
place during the show's sixth season was
the culmination of a long chain of
events that included Jon Snow's reunion
with his sister Sansa her escape from
her sociopathic husband Ramsay Bolton
and The long-awaited Showdown among them
all as with many battles on Game of
Thrones each moment is more brutal than
the last and throughout the fight it
seems unlikely that Jon Snow will emerge
Victorious at one point he ends up
submerged in a pile of dead bodies and
living soldiers gasping for breath as he
struggles to rise to the surface which
reportedly terrified actor kit
Harrington who plays Snow he didn't
enjoy this part of filming as being
crushed is one of his biggest fears he
gave up his own Comfort to create a
singular moment for viewers
speaking of Ramsay Bolton when viewers
met the character played by Ewan Rian in
season three he was a bastard much like
Jon Snow when he helped his father Bruce
Bolton secure the north he was made an
official Bolton in his own right after
watching Ramsay generally be the worst
person of all time fans were thrilled
when Ramsay met a bitter and bloody end
in the aftermath of the battle of the
bastards it was especially satisfying to
hear him being torn apart by his own
pack of angry attack dogs
they're loyal beasts they were
now they're starving but before that
goes down once the larger battle ends
John and Ramsay find themselves back at
Winterfell ready to keep fighting John
snaps and brutally beats Ramsay into
submission however some of this ended up
becoming a reality for Rion who was
actually punched in the face twice by
Harrington Harrington said Rihanna was
extremely nice about the situation but
it's unlikely that Rihanna was thrilled
about taking two for the team
since debuting on the show during season
two Brienne of Tarth played by actress
Gwendolyn Christie has won audiences
hearts with her fierce battle skills
unerring loyalty and quick quips after
serving a few Fallen characters
including Catelyn Stark Brienne strikes
up a real friendship with Jaime
Lannister between her bond with the
kingslayer and her continued Devotion to
Catelyn Brienne has become a fan
favorite as such fans are always
frightened when Brienne ends up in a
life-threatening situation when Brienne
and Jaime are captured and held hostage
by Locke a hunter for House Bolton Locke
forces Brienne to face down a real bear
in a fighting pit causing Jaime to come
in and rescue her although Christy said
the bear was a diva requiring its own
trailer she also said it was terrifying
to face down the giant animal with
nothing more than an electric fence
between them and you believe them I
think I look so scared
few of Thrones villains have elicited a
public reaction quite as visceral as
Joffrey Baratheon the sadistic eldest
son of Cersei Lannister a bitter violent
hungry child born of incest King
Joffrey's vengeful and ill-advised
decision to execute Ned Stark in the
Show's first season set off most of the
entire story's conflict so long as I'm
your king treason shall never go
unpunished
sir Ellen
bring me his head viewers have watched
him murder sex workers threatened to
beat women and verbally abuse pretty
much everyone it's no wonder viewers
loved watching Joffrey get slapped he
meets an extremely ugly End early in the
fourth season during his wedding to
Marjorie Tyrell Joffrey takes a final
sip of wine gruesomely choking to death
in front of the entire court actor Jack
Gleason quit acting after his last
moments as Joffrey he said that aside
from the choking itself keeping his eyes
open was the hardest part they actually
had to be held open so he didn't blink
making filming the scene that much more
uncomfortable
Cersei Lannister yet another throne's
character that viewers love to hate has
committed her fair share of atrocities
you know stuff like enabling her evil
son Joffrey carrying on a decades-long
affair with her twin brother and
slaughtering most of King's Landing by
burning them with Wildfire she got her
just desserts for some of her crimes at
the end of the show's fifth season when
she was forced to take a walk of
atonement through King's Landing
completely naked while the townspeople
verbally and physically abused her the
walk was shot in Dubrovnik Croatia near
an ancient Church the production was
nearly banned however due to the nudity
in the end actress Lena Headey asked for
a body double thanks to the magic of
visual effects Rebecca van cleave's body
stood in for cersei's Van Cleef spent
three days walking the streets of
Dubrovnik completely naked while crew
members and Extras shouted and pelted
her with Food Van cleave's face was
never shown
after a number of shocking deaths
throughout throne's run viewers have
accepted the idea that nobody is safe
which made Jon Snow's false start of a
death all the more horrifying during the
season 5 finale John now the Lord
commander of the Night's Watch is
betrayed by his men and repeatedly
stabbed over accusations of treason the
show cuts to Black leaving anxious fans
without answers regarding Jon's fate
until the next season premiere actor kit
Harrington told various media Outlets he
would not be returning to the show which
turned out to be a pretty enormous lie
Jon was alive and well by the second
episode of the next season Harrington
reportedly hated lying with huge fans
like President Barack Obama concerned
about Jon Snow's fate Harrington had to
play it extremely safe for over a year
he did get himself out of a speeding
ticket by revealing one of the show's
biggest spoilers to an anxious police
officer so at least there was some
silver lining to this sacrifice I looked
at him when
I I'm alive next season and he goes he
says
on your way Lord come on
throughout Game of Thrones run Arya
Stark has transformed from a young
impetuous would-be Warrior to a truly
dangerous faceless assassin after
watching her father's public execution
and making the journey from Westeros to
the house of the undying in braavos she
agrees to learn from the mysterious Face
Changer Jacqueline Hagar she waits
outside the house for days to earn her
place inside as soon as Arya learns how
to change faces she uses her power to
kill Merlin Trant but because it wasn't
yet merwin's turn to die Arya is
punished by Jacques who blinds her and
forces her to live as a beggar while
blind arya's eyes are clouded
unfortunately for actress Maisie
Williams her contacts were quite thick
and hand-painted actually obscuring her
vision Williams admitted that while she
didn't want to complain her blind scenes
left her in a significant amount of pain
she stuck with it ensuring that each
shot during arya's blind phase was
exactly right
Dion Greyjoy the once cocky heir to the
iron islands has been through his fair
share of ordeals once a young stubborn
ward of the north Theon was initially
loyal to Rob Stark in the wake of Ned's
death eventually he betrayed Rob and was
captured by the sadistic Ramsay Bolton
who physically and psychologically
destroyed Theon until he referred to
himself as reek perhaps the hardest
scenes for actor Alfie Allen to endure
throughout Thrones were his torture
scenes with Ramsay he spent most of a
full season strung up savagely mutilated
and beaten it can't have been easy for
Alan to even pretend to be tortured and
he has since spoken out about how hard
it was to play he watched movies that
prominently featured torture including
Quentin Tarantino's bloody classic
Reservoir Dogs spending so much time
within this unflinchingly terrible part
of theon's story must have been
incredibly difficult for Alan
some viewers might have forgotten about
Lancel Lannister played by Eugene Simon
when audiences meet a younger Lancel he
is a seemingly innocent Squire to King
Robert until the Monarch's death after
an ill-advised affair with his cousin
Cersei which is somehow not the grossest
relationship she has in the show Lancel
is severely wounded in season 2's Battle
of Blackwater Bay and shunted to the
sidelines when Lancel returns he's
joined in oppressive and severe
religious sect called The Sparrows when
Lancel spills the beans about his
relationship with Cersei she gets
angrier than ever rather than attend her
own trial the vengeful Queen Mother
unleashes a magical Wildfire throughout
King's Landing killing numerous people
Lancel sent to find the missing Cersei
during her trial discovers her plan he
can't stop the explosion in time despite
his best efforts Simon spent hours
crawling through a dark dungeon enduring
the journey a whopping 27 times until
they got the shot right
ready for some Game of Thrones season 7
spoilers no too bad bend the knee and
keep watching because Game of Thrones as
season 7 premiere was memorable for many
things like Arya Stark's avengeful
assault on the frey family Daenerys
Targaryen finally reaching Dragonstone
euron Greyjoy declaring himself for
Queen Cersei and the Sansa giving Jon
Snow some serious sass but Despite All
That season 7 already sucks you know why
because Joffrey is not in it
I miss you Joffrey
so much
but that was all a bit overshadowed by
The Cameo of Ed Sheeran whose musical
moment on the show was unintentionally
hilarious
it's a pretty song I've never heard it
before it's a new one
Sheeran stints as a Lannister Soldier
might have earned a roaring social media
response but it was just one in a series
of celebrity cameos that have come and
gone on the show here are some other
famous faces who have popped up in the
realm over the years
Gary lightbody Sharon was hardly the
first musician to appear on Game of
Thrones in season 3 snow patrol front
man Gary lightbody leads a battalion of
House Bolton soldiers in a rendition of
the bear under the Maiden Fair in the
world of Westeros this is a folk song
everybody seems to know but in the real
world it was necessary to make audiences
aware that the song exists so that a
later episode could take that title and
run with a very literal interpretation
of it
Roy Dotrice if you're a long time fan of
fantasy on television you probably
remember Roy dotries as Ron Pullman's
wise father figure on Beauty and the
Beast but if you're a fan of George R.R
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire you
probably know him as a celebrated reader
of the audiobooks he was personally
chosen by Martin after the two had
worked together on Beauty and the Beast
and was originally announced as Grand
Amaze to pyzel for the HBO series due to
health reasons he was replaced by Julian
Glover but fortunately he was able to
appear in season 2 as the pyromancer
halene while he isn't on screen much
harleen plays a key role in tyrion's
master plan for the Battle of Blackwater
so it's a fitting use of an actor who
will forever be linked to the books
David benioff and DB Weiss the house of
black and white where Arya Stark
receives her training as a mystical
assassin features an endless Hall filled
with columns lined with the faces of the
Dead not statues but the actual faces
that have been removed and serve as
masks for The Faceless Men naturally the
production does design staff who made
the faces ended up including people they
know most notably show creators benioff
and Weiss whose faces occupy ad Jason's
compartments that receive a bit of
camera time
Mastodon the American heavy metal band
Mastodon didn't perform music on Game of
Thrones but they did contribute a song
called White Walker to the catch the
throne Vol 2 mixtape HBO released to tie
into the show in 2015. so it wasn't
surprising when members of the band
showed up in the episode hard home in
which they are killed and then
resurrected by the White Walkers the
band can thank A Game of Thrones
executive producer D.B Weiss for those
collaborative opportunities because he's
apparently a big fan of the group George
W bush in Game of Thrones first season
Sansa was made to look upon her father's
severed head by the cruel new King
Joffrey and while your eyes may be
scarred by the image of poor Lord Stark
there are tons of other spiked heads on
display alongside him including one
resembling former U.S President George W
bush which rests next to Sansa scepter
Benny often Weiss revealed that they
used the already existing head prop for
the scene because of their need for
heads not for any kind of political
statement but once the word got out some
people found such a violent depiction of
a former president to be disrespectful
this led to official apologies from HBO
as well as Benny often Weiss Seeger Ross
another memorable musical Cameo comes at
Joffrey and marjorie's wedding in season
four the Icelandic post-rock band to see
grass shows up with a strange set of
musical instruments to perform a droning
Take On The House Lannister song The
reigns of Castamere it did not please
the king
good very good off you go
Will Champion in one of the most
chilling episodes of the entire series
Coldplay drummer Will Champion join the
cast to bang the drums and the halls of
the twins before all hell broke loose
he's shown merrily thumping away as
emiatulli and his new bride are sent to
their wedding bed blissfully unaware of
the Red Wedding Massacre that's about to
go down
was a very strange custom
Noah syndergaard Ed Sheeran wasn't the
only familiar phase to make his debut in
Season Seven New York Mets pitcher Noah
syndergaard also made a buzzy cameo in
the new season as one of house
Lannister's foot soldiers who has
incredible aim with spear throwing we
don't know if his character survived the
ensuing dragon attack but in light of
how the rest of the army fared he
probably didn't last long in the
Skirmish and considering the Mets 2017
season he's probably used to it
with so many big world shaking things
happening in every episode of Game of
Thrones it can be easy to overlook some
of the smaller moments here's a
spoiler-filled look at some things only
real fans noticed in the final season of
Game of Thrones since the beginning of
the show Daenerys has adopted different
traditions and styles from the various
tribes and groups she's LED and joined
and perhaps the most influential group
in her young life is the Dothraki thanks
to the fact that she became a queen of
the warrior tribe upon her marriage to
Khal Drogo the Dothraki plays an
enormous importance upon the length and
style of their hair especially for the
men the more braids and man Sports the
more victories he's won in battle and a
Dothraki Warrior only cuts his hair if
he loses a fight so the longer the main
the more formidable the Warrior when
Dothraki defeated in combat cut off
their brain so the whole world can see
the machine Carl Drogo as never defeated
as a result Daenerys has sported a
lengthy name featuring a fierce tangle
of braids from several seasons but the
fifth episode of the eighth season finds
her at a disadvantage having lost two of
her most trusted advisors Jorah and
masande when Tyrion checks on her at
Dragonstone her braids are must undone
and ragged letting the audience know
that the dragon Queen is losing her grip
and will end up risking everything to
get back on top when Daenerys was
married to the warrior Lord Khal Drogo
and Thrones his first season she didn't
anticipate having to fight all of her
own battles mostly because Drogo a
prideful and formidable fighter was all
too happy to wage war on her behalf when
Daenerys told them she was pregnant with
his son who was prophesied to be a
messiah-like figure known as the
stallion who would Mount the world Drogo
made a passionate promise to take the
Iron Throne on daenerys's behalf
completely
that sort of violent destruction is
exactly what Daenerys and her Dothraki
hordes Unleashed on King's Landing in
the fifth episode of The Final Season it
seemed out of character until you
remember that Daenerys made a similar
pact with the Dothraki back in season
six
good morning
looks like she has more than kept both
of those promises
after losing her husband Daenerys made
several attempts to find armies and
benefactors to back her in the war to
come and during thrones's second season
she ran afoul of the warlocks of cars
who stole her dragons and lured her into
the terrifying and mystical House of the
undying to get them back naturally
Daenerys charged into the temple to
track down her children and experienced
a number of Visions along the way seeing
everything from her late husband Drogo
and their Lost Child to a battered and
seemingly destroyed Iron Throne standing
in an empty and ravaged throne room it
seems as if Daenerys is surrounded by
snow but thanks to the aftermath of
King's Landing in the wake of her
ruthless and murderous Siege it's clear
that her vision has come true and it's
not snow but ashes many viewers always
believe that the snow was a sign of the
night King but perhaps at this point
daenerys's Reign of Fire and Blood is
even more dangerous and destructive than
the night King himself and before long
audiences will likely see Daenerys
standing in the real ransacked version
of the throne room ready and determined
to take whatever is left of the Iron
Throne itself
[Music]
being cast on Game of Thrones can be a
mixed blessing on one hand acting in
HBO's hottest series can seriously boost
your acting resume on the other hand
given the show's history you're probably
gonna get killed off sooner or later as
this long list of casualties can attest
here's a look at some of the major
characters who have died on the show and
were the actors who played them are
today Harry Lloyd viserys Targaryen he
was supposed to be the true king of
Westeros but for Sarah's Targaryen was
the first major character to meet his
maker on Game of Thrones when Carl Drogo
crowned him with molten gold during
season one actor Harry Lloyd has kept
himself busy since dying on Game of
Thrones continuing to act on television
and in movies like The Theory of
Everything Mark Addy Robert Baratheon
after a hunting trip gone wrong in
season 1 King Robert Baratheon first of
his name died prompting his best friend
Ned Stark to take action against the
machinations of Cersei and Joffrey since
leaving Thrones star Mark ADI has
surfaced on several television series
including Great Expectations and The
Syndicate Sean Bean Ned Stark after
Robert's death Ned Stark tried to take
control sending a letter to Robert's
brother Stannis inviting him to come
take his rightful place on the throne
unfortunately for Ned Cersei was two
steps ahead of him and Ned famously lost
his head on The Executioner's block at
the end of season one you know which is
a very you know he sacrificed himself
for his family so he was a very moving a
very touching moment and um and a good
way to go really although being has a
reputation for being killed off in many
of his projects He hasn't let that stop
his acting career since Thrones he's
appeared in a variety of projects
including the Martian and the Legends
and some of his other recent work
includes roles in the six-part BBC
miniseries broken and the 2017 Thriller
film drone Jason Momoa Carl Drogo
although Cole Drogo was dead essentially
from the moment the old evil witch lady
infected his wound with a fake medicine
his actual death was much more tragic as
Daenerys had to suffocate him with a
pillow to put him out of his misery at
the end of season 1. Jason momoa's brief
Game of Thrones tenure served him well
in Hollywood leading to win the role of
Aquaman in the DC extended Universe
films Batman vs Superman Justice League
and 2018's Aquaman solo adventure and
Momoa seems like he's enjoying the ride
Captain Anthony Renly Baratheon for
following King Robert's death his
younger brother Renly attempted to claim
the throne Renly had one of the largest
armies in the Seven Kingdoms and was
beloved by everyone everyone except his
brother Stannis however who used black
magic to murder Renly in season two
after Game of Thrones actor gathan
Anthony appeared in the 2014 film
Copenhagen as well as the popular series
called the Midwife then demonstrated his
range by playing Charles Manson in the
NBC period crime drama Aquarius he also
provided the voice of Gil Brody in the
video game Mass Effect Andromeda Oona
Chaplin Talisa maiger standing in for
the book character of Jane westerling
Talisa maigar married Rob Stark the king
in the north unfortunately Rob was
already engaged to the granddaughter of
Lord Walder Frey who exacted his Revenge
by murdering Talisa at the Red Wedding
in season three After Game of Thrones
Oona Chaplin starred in the 2014
mini-series the Crimson field and an
episode of the popular television show
black mirror as well as a 2015 movie The
Longest Ride
Richard Madden Rob Stark the king in the
north Robb Stark met his end beside his
beloved Talisa taking a knife to the
heart from the traitorous Bruce Bolton
it was a traumatic way for actor Richard
Madden to end his time on the show and
managed to get on the plane covered in
fake blood I was kind of upset at the
end of the whole job and I kind of
looked I think I looked like I'd
murdered someone then got on a flight
following his exit from Game of Thrones
in 2014 Madonna appeared in the series
Medici masters of Florence and does the
print in the 2015 live action Disney
adaptation of Cinderella Madden can be
seen in the 2017 Amazon original series
Oasis Michelle Fairley Catelyn Stark
though Catelyn dedicated her life to
protecting her children she died at the
Red Wedding believing she had failed
them all since her terrible death in
season 3 actress Michelle Fairley has
stayed busy with projects including the
television series Resurrection and the
movie in the heart of the sea as well as
the Stars miniseries the white princess
Jack Gleason Joffrey Baratheon
thankfully the reign of Psychopathic boy
King Joffrey Baratheon came to an early
end Joffrey married the widowed Marjorie
Tyrell but his reputation as an evil
jerk preceded him so her grandmother
protected her by slipping some fast
action poison into his cup of the
reception Jacob Gleason retired from
screen acting After Game of Thrones but
he remains involved in the Arts he
founded collapsing horse Theater Company
in Ireland which won an award for their
puppet show bears in space at the 2016
first Irish theater Festival in New York
City
considering how much has packed into
every episode of Game of Thrones it
might come as a surprise that there are
plenty of scenes filmed for the show
that never make it to air luckily HBO
has included many of these deleted
scenes as bonus features for their home
releases and some of these scenes
provide important character details and
even hints at future events here's a
look at the most important deleted
scenes from Game of Thrones loras and
Marjorie season 2. in this deleted scene
from season 2 lorus and Marjorie comfort
each other following the murder of runly
Baratheon at the hands of Stannis
Baratheon and melisandre's shadow
assassin Loris has clearly more
grief-dricken than his sister which
makes sense given Randy was his true
love more importantly viewers got an
early glimpse into marjorie's always
scheming mind as she carefully steers
Loris away from grief and towards a more
pragmatic future supporting her next
political move he was a good man
he was a kind sweet man but he's gone
now he doesn't need you anymore I need
you our family needs you Daria and Erie
season two during the second season of
Game of Thrones Daenerys learned that
important lesson in trust when her
handmaiden Daria betrayed her murdering
the Khaleesi's confidante Erie in the
process fans didn't actually see any of
that happen but the sequence was
actually filmed before being cut later
in an interview after her departure from
Game of Thrones actress and Rita acharya
who played Erie revealed that she was
trying so hard to make the strangulation
scene realistic that she actually
suffered real injuries to her neck while
filming I had massive bruises on my neck
the next day I was proud Battle Scars
death scenes are fun Sansa the hound and
Tyrion season 2. sandor Clegane has had
one of the most dramatic character arcs
of anyone on the show as the hounder
slowly embraced his Humanity that
Journey began with his relation ship of
the imprisoned suns are in season two
but it was a rocky beginning as this
deleted scene shows would you sing a
song for me little bird a song about
Knights and fair maidens
go on scene
you won't hurt me the scene ends of
Tyrion intervening on behalf of his
future wife giving this brief deleted
sequence yet another layer of
foreshadowing paisal and Tywin season
three although the audience suspects
that pie style is playing his own long
game the other residents of King's
Landing never quite seemed to realize
that grand maester isn't nearly as
feeble as he pretends to be but in this
deleted scene we discover that Tywin has
known all along more shockingly paiso
reveals that it was his treachery that
allowed the Lannisters to conquer the
Seven Kingdoms in the first place since
the time I convinced the Mad King to
open his gates to you
I have served the interests of the House
of Lannister unfailingly given how much
goes on in this short scene it's a bit
surprising they left it on the Cutting
Room floor bran and Shea season four
after Tyrion ends his relationship with
shea in season four he sends her away to
pentas where he hopes she will be safe
later she shockingly resurfaces to
testify against him at his trial why
well the seeds for that were actually
planted in a deleted scene where
tyrion's buddy Brawn delivers the bad
news along with a speech about how rich
people are all total jerks you can
almost see Shay's love twisting to spite
as he talks these people
even the good ones I use this as a
police
and when we're no longer in the use the
spit us out find someone else they like
good job Braun gray worm and missande
season five in this deleted sequence
from season five we get to see an
extended version of a scene between
masande and gray worm after the
unsullied named white rat was killed in
a Marine brothel we get to see a hint of
the beginning of the romance between
gray Rome and musande as she tells him
that she is afraid what might happen to
him if the sons of the harpy attack you
will be careful
careful
he will protect yourself I protect
Daenerys Stormborn of course shortly
after this gray worm was nearly killed
only surviving thanks to the sacrifice
of Sir barriston next time listen to
your girlfriend Arya and the Mummers
season six in several parts of season
six Arya works with the troop of Mummers
in braavos as they perform their satire
of restorosi current events the bloody
hand but not everyone in the audience
enjoys a performance as much as Aya as
shown in this deleted scene violence and
profanity how original
why don't you just leave them if you're
familiar with the controversy
surrounding the show after the events
following sansa's wedding to Ramsay Snow
in season five it's not hard to
recognize this deleted scene as a subtle
dig at viewers who complain about the
show but continue to tune in anyway I'm
going in a wild boar hunt
from coffee breaks to disappearing
extras and rubber swords there have been
some unexpected sights in Westeros over
the years here's a few of the biggest
on-screen mistakes you can catch and
chuckle at throughout Game of Thrones
during the fourth episode of Game of
Thrones 8th and final season the
majority of the show's characters found
themselves celebrating their Victory
against the army of the dead at
Winterfell in a raucous party scene
filled with drinking games dirty jokes
and even a marriage proposal as Jon Snow
is venerated by his friends for his
Valiant efforts during the Battle of
Winterfell and Daenerys watches a coffee
cup is clearly visible on the table in
front of her sticking out like a sore
thumb among mugs of Ale goblets of wine
another medieval style props typical of
thrones's time and style naturally fans
didn't let this pass quietly and they
stormed the internet to make a million
Starbucks jokes and even the cats got in
on the joke HBO for their part released
a jokey statement about the mistake but
went on to digitally remove the cup from
the episode throughout the series run
Game of Thrones viewers have watched
Daenerys Targaryen pick up titles amass
armies free the downtrodden and
experience enormous overall character
growth as she evolves from a Meek naive
child bride to one of the most powerful
players in the Seven Kingdoms as she
fights her way to the Iron Throne
Daenerys learns New Traditions from the
different tribes and people she
encounters along the way and one of them
has to do with her hair and its very
specific styling thanks to daenerys's
First Love called Drogo one of
daenerys's signature Traditions is to
keep her hair long and continue to add
complicated braids to her updos braids
indicate battle victories for the
Dothraki and long hair means you haven't
yet been defeated by your enemies with
that many braid wigs laying around it's
probably hard to keep track and
sharp-eyed viewers caught a rare wig
error during the first episode of
thrones's eighth season as Daenerys
rides into Winterfell alongside Jon Snow
her wig visibly changes displaying a
totally different braid style between
two quick shots daenerys's hair is a
pretty important symbol but sometimes
even the crew probably he has trouble
remembering which rig goes on when that
many wigs would make anyone go a little
crazy throughout eight seasons fans have
become quite familiar with Game of
Thrones sets and various locations since
the beginning the show has made use of
incredible natural beauty across the
world to bring the Seven Kingdoms to
life from quiet Shores in Spain to The
Rolling Green Hills of Northern Ireland
snowy spots in Iceland and ancient
Croatian cities Thrones has utilized
some of the most gorgeous places on
Earth to serve as stand-ins for these
Fantastical locations these incredible
filming locations give the show a sense
of enormous scale and richness that
digital effects alone would never create
as the capital of the Seven Kingdoms
King's Landing is one of the grandest
locations on the show positioned as a
large city that sits directly on the sea
even though it gets a Digital Makeover
every time it shows up that city is
actually a real place Thrones set their
King's Landing scenes in the real city
of Dubrovnik Croatia known as The Jewel
of the Adriatic which now draws Boards
of visitors every year thanks to its
prominent screen time on the show for
the vast majority of that screen time
the gates of King's Landing looked out
on a green pastoral space and then in
season eight it looked a little drier
[Music]
yeah it took on a totally new look with
an expanse of flat empty desert
stretching out from the capitol if
viewers had never seen the gates before
this might make some sense but
considering that audiences have spent
plenty of time looking at King's Landing
this continuity error is especially
jarring a coffee cup spotted during
season Eight's the last of the Starks
inspired plenty of jokes but thanks to
long hours and grueling shoot schedules
there's bound to be plenty of coffee
cups laying around thrones's set and
most people don't know that this wasn't
even the first errant cup to be spotted
on the series during season 4 episode 2
The Lion and the rose which focused
almost entirely on an ill-fated Royal
Wedding a behind the scenes shot of the
Lannister Clan catches Jaime Lannister
clutching a coffee cup of his own
fortunately this blender wasn't nearly
as bad as the internet made it out to be
since the scene was part of a behind the
scenes featurette that didn't make it to
the episode it didn't attract as much
attention as daenerys's cup of herbal
tea in season 8. but it still goes to
show that there are plenty of caffeine
habits waiting to slip up the stars on
the set of Game of Thrones the opening
credits of Game of Thrones have been
lauded for their well-designed
imaginative take on the series giving
fans plenty of Easter eggs throughout
the years as well as spotlighting each
location prominently featured in each
season after years of moving across the
Seven Kingdoms with stylized moving
models of each major city or location
popping up to show where fans might find
their favorite characters this time the
season 8 title sequence changed
considerably focusing on the North and
King's Landing as the massive war
between the two factions of Westeros
draws to a bloody close another little
detail during the opening credits is the
fact that each actor Bears a Sigil next
to their name in the credits identifying
their House of the Seven Kingdoms from
Starks to targaryens to Lannisters but
every now and then in the early Seasons
someone would end up identified with the
completely wrong house maybe the
showrunners hadn't quite figured out how
the credits would work yet but during
the first season Sophie Turner who plays
Sans the Stark was suddenly a Targaryen
Emilia Clarke who plays Daenerys
Targaryen herself ended up marked as a
Lannister and Ian Glenn who plays
daenerys's faithful right-hand man Jorah
Mormont was also apparently a secret
Lannister this show does have a lot of
characters to keep track of but these
particularly obvious gaffs probably
could have been avoided it's worth
noting that these mistakes have
apparently been remedied since they
first showed up one of the most serious
afflictions in throne's lore is known as
grayscale a super contagious virus-like
disease that turns human skin into a
stone-like substance and makes the
victim both unrecognizable and insane
spread by touch greyscale is notorious
and deeply feared even when the spread
of it can be stopped as it was for
Shireen Baratheon most of Westeros
agrees that grayscale is incurable and
must be quarantined even though the
audience learns later that you can
apparently just cut it all off and be
perfectly fine but nobody knew that
during the show's Fifth Season as Jorah
Mormont and Tyrion Lannister travel
through ancient valyria to track down
Daenerys while floating into the city on
their boat they encounter a group of
Violent Men all Afflicted with serious
grayscale
although Tyrion escapes their clutches
Jorah ends up with a patch of grayscale
on his wrist and resigns himself to a
slow death during which he'll never
touch another person a short while later
however when Jorah and Tyrion have met
up with Daenerys in the fighting pits of
marine Jorah straight up takes
daenerys's hand to save her life since
he still has grayscale at this point he
could have transmitted the disease and
killed her simply by touching her after
taking great care to illustrate that
Jorah can't touch anyone at all so as
not to infect them this seems like a
pretty massive oversight even in the
middle of a tense battle scene Game of
Thrones is no stranger to huge Battle
Set pieces and season six is the Battle
of the bastards a long-awaited showdown
between Jon Snow and Ramsay Bolton was
no exception pitting the underdog Stark
family against the sadistic Bolton Clan
considered one of the best episodes of
the entire series The Battle of the
bastards combined an incredibly
choreographed and gorgeously shot battle
sequence with real emotional heft and an
incredibly satisfying ending goodbye
Ramsay
surprised that fans and critics alike
venerated the popular episode which
scooped up a whopping seven Emmy Awards
and categories that included writing and
directing fans were thrilled to see Jon
charge into righteous battle with his
sword longclaw but in one particular
shot something seems to be a little
wrong with the blade as Jon jumps onto
his horse to enter The Fray his sword
literally bends making it obvious that
kit Harrington was outfitted with a
rubber sword for this particular shot
Jon probably won't take down any enemies
with this but it at least gave viewers a
good laugh after the episode aired
this is Valyrian steel during the show's
third season Jon Snow infiltrates a
group of wildlings only to fall in love
with Egret a fierce fire-haired Warrior
who spends most of her time telling Jon
Snow how much he knows
you know nothing
eventually Egret Falls hard for Jon in
return and the two of them set out to
scale the wall and make their way into
Westeros with a few other wildlings
though Jon eventually returns to the
Night's Watch betraying Egret she still
can't bring herself to kill him and
eventually dies in his arms when the
wildlings stage an attack on the Night's
Watch leaving Jon feeling pretty dang
sad at the loss of his first love egret
and Jon are still pretty hot and heavy
by the time they reach the top of the
wall along with a few other wildlings
and as they look out at the Green
Landscape of Westeros they kiss
passionately elated by their achievement
however their kiss is so powerful it
apparently knocks any other wildlings
right back off the wall they just
climbed since everybody else vanishes by
the end of the shot wanting some privacy
for such an epic romantic moment is
understandable but that's just taking it
too far on a huge show like Thrones
there's bound to be some prop accidents
especially when a lot of the props
involved are enormous metal swords meant
to look as menacing as possible as with
all fantasy series swords carry a lot of
weight with characters gifting naming
and gushing over specific weapons that
travel throughout the show a perfect
example is Ned Stark's sword ice which
is melted down after his execution and
made into two new swords named widow's
whale and oath keeper needless to say
swords on the show are treated with all
kinds of respect but sometimes extras
might have a little trouble managing
these massive weapons as Sir baristan
selmy is unwillingly discharged from the
kingsguard during the first season
there's a tense moment in which it looks
like sir barriston might try to start a
fight fortunately the moment is diffused
without Bloodshed and bariston storms
off into retirement at which point all
the guards sheath their swords in one
smooth motion like the pros they are
foreign
put their swords back one of the extras
has some trouble getting his sword back
into his sheath which embarrassingly for
that extra ended up making it into the
Final Cut
Daenerys Targaryen played by Emilia
Clarke quickly became one of the most
popular characters in Game of Thrones
audiences hopped on board her hell-bent
mission to bring her rage to Westeros
and oust the Lannisters from the seat of
power the Iron Throne which Daenerys
believes is her Birthright the show
spends plenty of time developing her
character in a way that made audiences
feel incredibly sympathetic towards her
cause she's undoubtedly one of the
show's most beloved Heroes I need to be
more than that once she fully came into
her own commanding armies and fighting
for justice Daenerys was indisputably a
brilliant and compelling character not
to mention the addition of her dragons
which only made fans invest in her Quest
even further while it was obvious what
producers DB wise and David benioff were
trying to say about the Allure that true
power holds and how it easily corrupts
people one particular scene took things
too far this is of course when Daenerys
burned King's Landing it's a moment that
unfortunately turned fans against
Daenerys in the final season of Game of
Thrones okay sure Daenerys burned people
alive using her dragons a number of
times but it's the intention behind the
destruction of King's Landing that just
took things too far now we can admit
that Daenerys was in a bad place Jon
Snow played by kit Harrington rejected
her because he discovers they're related
yikes she loses both her closest
Confidant missande played by Natalie
Emanuel and one of her two remaining
dragons to cersei's forces Daenerys has
nothing left to lose which leads to the
complete destruction of King's Landing
in season 8 episode 5. The Bells it's
completely Daenerys choice to willingly
burn probably thousands of innocent
people including women and children
alive in the streets the civilian's
collective terror is truly fell
throughout the episode with a war
happening on the ground in a
fire-breathing dragon hovering in the
sky at this point Daenerys is no longer
a liberator it's a complete departure
from and portrayal of the woman who was
so dedicated to freeing slaves for the
past seven seasons when faced with
King's Landing Daenerys kills thousands
of people simply because she can as the
battle rages Jon is horrified by her
actions when he sees the burnt bodies of
men women and children litter the ground
it's only further hammered home that
Dany is truly off the deep end when she
announces in the season finale the Iron
Throne that she was planning to extend
her wrath across the rest of the World
John ultimately faces an impossible
choice and kills his Queen aunt and
lover right in front of the throne she
wants so badly there's no question that
Daenerys a hot-blooded Targaryen with a
family history of mental instability and
massive dragons willing to do her
bidding made some troubling decisions
throughout Thrones still viewers could
always be comforted that she was on the
right side of justice that is until the
show's final season the creative minds
behind Game of Thrones maintained that
the Daenerys twist was planned all along
and it makes sense with her character
however the Daenerys that audiences fell
for would never have killed innocence
though Clark initially defended the
finale back in May of 2019 saying
Daenerys destruction was a logical route
for the character to take she has since
reversed cores during a June 2021 chat
with MTV News correspondent Josh
Horowitz on this podcast Clark said I
get why people were pissed I totally get
it though Clark said she did have some
quote autonomy over Daenerys character
arc when all was said and done she just
had to play what was given to her as
truthfully as possible she added the
editor decides what it looks like and
the writer decides what I'm saying so
you just gotta go in and try and give it
as much truth and honesty in yourself as
you possibly can whether you want to
relive daenerys's best moments or yell
through the Bells all over again all of
Game of Thrones is available to stream
on HBO Max
[Music]
if you clicked on this video then let's
just get this out of the way up front
there are Major Spoilers ahead for the
most recent episode of Game of Thrones
last warning before things turn into a
spoiler-filled free-for-all entitled The
Bells the latest Game of Thrones episode
saw Daenerys Targaryen and her Allied
Forces carry out their Siege of King's
Landing it all came off the back of Dany
witnessing Cersei Lannister executing
her friend misande and Daenerys herself
executing Varys after he betrayed her
clearly Daenerys wasn't in the calmest
or most rational State of Mind when she
and her troops rocked up to the
westerosi capital watching misande be
decapitated quickly realizing that
people in Westeros love Jon Snow and
will support his legitimate claim to the
iron throne and the understanding that
she only knows fear in the country
proved too much for Daenerys she
Unleashed fire and fury on King's
Landing commanding her Dragon to burn
the city down even after its people rang
the bells and surrendered but it wasn't
just dragon fire that blazed through
King's Landing burst of emerald Flames
erupted throughout the city too for
those who may not recall that's Wildfire
a highly flammable and Incredibly
volatile liquid created by the
pyromancers of the ancient Society known
as The Alchemist Guild Wildfire begins
as a bright green liquid and burns with
great strength when it's ignited it
doesn't carry quite the same properties
as normal fire as it cannot be
extinguished with water only with sand
season 8 episode 5 wasn't the first time
viewers caught a glimpse of wildfire of
course Cersei utilizes a huge cache of
wildfire hidden beneath the sept of
Balor to blow up the place of worship
during season six which kills then Queen
Marjorie Tyrell
foreign
that allows Cersei to claim the Iron
Throne after her son king Tom and
Baratheon takes his own life following
the fiery Carnage Wildfire appears in
season 2 as well when Tyrion Lannister
learns that Cersei is planning to use
Wildfire as a weapon of defense against
Stannis Baratheon in his Fleet on
Blackwater Bay Tyrion and Braun pay a
visit to the head of the Alchemist Guild
in King's Landing just ahead of the
battle of the Blackwater The Alchemist
tells Tyrion and Braun that Wildfire
might be potent enough to burn off
people's appendages and then highlights
an intense connection between wildfire
and House Targaryen
after the dragons died Wildfire was the
key to the Targaryen power
Wildfire was discussed again during
season three on the fifth episode of
That season Jaime Lannister reveals the
true reason he slaughtered the Mad King
heiress the Tyrant wanted to burn every
last inch of King's Landing using
Wildfire the Mad King realizing that his
opponents were going to win the battle
had his pyromancers tucked stores of
wildfire in various locations throughout
King's Landing Jaime explains to Brienne
of Tarth that the Mad King was obsessed
with the stuff and he loved watching his
enemies burn it Burns Lords he didn't
like he burned hands disobeyed and he
burned
anyone who was against him
as past seasons have established
Wildfire is a chosen weapon of House
Targaryen one that its members favored
when its greatest advantage over the
Seven Kingdoms their dragons all died
out it only makes sense that Wildfire
would appear again when Daenerys the
last living child of the Mad King let
the devastation of death the reality of
fear and the overwhelming desire for
power turned her into a version of her
father the Mad King attempted to burn
King's Landing with wildfire and
couldn't but his daughter finished the
job decades later it's almost guaranteed
that the Wildfire scene on season 8
episode 5 came from the stores that the
Mad King's pyromancers placed across
King's Landing ones no one had found
until Danny ordered drogon to blast his
Flames everywhere it also draws yet
another terrifying parallel between
Daenerys and her father the man she
tried so hard not to become up to this
point will she suffer the same fate he
did killed by a knight with a swift hand
the final episode of Game of Thrones
will reveal the answer
the former head of house Stark has
spilled the beans about his final
moments on Game of Thrones even after
seven more seasons of pain and bloodshed
the death of eddard Stark still stings
played by Sean Bean Ned Stark was
originally positioned as the closest
thing the expansive fantasy series had
to a main character making it extra
devastating and effective when he met
his maker at the end of the first season
for those who don't exactly remember
what happened to Ned he falsely
confessed to treason after Robert
Baratheon died in a hunting accident
calculated by Cersei Lannister and
cersei's Son Joffrey took the Iron
Throne Ned questioned Joffrey's claim to
the throne then Cersei had him locked up
and demanded he own up to treason though
Ned's daughter Sansa and Cersei both
asked Joffrey to reconsider the little
tyrants ordered Ned to death by
beheading anyway so long as I'm your
king
treason shall never go unpunished
sir Ellen
bring me his head just before the blade
came down the Stark patriarch could be
seen Whispering a few words with none of
his last words be in Audible and the
books providing no Insight viewers have
been left to formulate their own guesses
as to what the former head of house
Stark may have said as he shuffled off
this Mortal coil from the obvious
possibility of the series's favorite
aphorism
which translates to all men must die
others have made more plot-specific
suggestions like the idea that Ned was
secretly stating that Jon Snow wasn't
his bastard son but the child of his
sister lyanna and rhaegar Targaryen in
an interview with the Huffington Post
actor Sean Bean Finally Revealed Ned's
last words they weren't an important
message with grand implications for the
plots nor a popular catchphrase in
actuality Ned said a simple quiet prayer
just before dying Bean explains that he
wanted to make Ned's death seem as
realistic as possible in a series that
features dragons and Men coming back to
life and a frosty villain who can
reanimate Corpses he said I couldn't be
too specific because I don't know if
religion like that was around in those
days whatever they were I just thought
what would you do if this were really
gonna happen you probably would pray you
probably would murmur some words and
keep it quiet you'd keep it to yourself
according to Bean he didn't set out to
give fans something to speculate on
saying he only spoke during the scene
because it felt right for the character
he added it's quite subtle in that many
people wouldn't pick it up it was an
interesting thing for me to do at that
point there's not much you can do really
you've got your head on a block that's
about the only thing you can do is
murmur the interview also confirmed that
bean has indeed seen all of the online
talk regarding his many on-screen
demises including a rundown from
nerdists that put the actors on-screen
death count just behind the oft murdered
Kenny from South Park according to the
actor he's pleased people are amused at
the unusual need she's carved out he
said oh I'll have to get some jobs some
dying jobs yeah I'm quite pleased with
that I don't mind being slightly behind
a cartoon character character on the
sort of bright side Ned Stark was far
from the last person to face an untimely
death throughout game of thrones's Run
Battle after battle after battle saw
dozens of major characters bite the dust
with the final season including some of
the most shocking impactful deaths of
the entire series another much beloved
hero was killed in the exact same manner
as Ned a swift sword chopped to the neck
ordered by a member of House Lannister
that character had but one final word to
say before dying
but Ned had a small list to peek out
with the way things are going on season
8 of Game of Thrones we just hope Ned's
prayer included a wish for everything to
turn out fine in Westeros
have Thor bjornsson better known as the
mountain that rides on HBO's Game of
Thrones isn't just one of the strongest
people on TV he's one of the strongest
people in the world out of this lean and
mean Icelander become the most fearsome
Knight in all of Westeros it hasn't
always been pretty
bjornsson was always a big person but
before he was the freakishly huge Mad
Dog of the Lannisters he was more tall
than he was wide instead of
weightlifting he put his talents to use
as a professional basketball player in
Iceland's first division as a younger
man bjornson says his weight hovered
around the 230 pound range which is
nothing compared to the near 400 pounds
he eventually achieved he said in an
interview with GQ I was always taller
than everybody else I've been training
all my life but probably didn't grow
muscly until I quit doing basketball his
naturally large frame gave him a big
advantage on the basketball courts but
he also was dedicated to working out and
getting better speaking to Men's Health
he said I was a bit crazy and trained a
lot probably three times a day before
school then afterwards plus I was
lifting at night his intense work ethic
paid off on the court but his basketball
days were plagued by a recurring ankle
injury which ultimately dashed his hoop
dreams he told GQ I was always getting
injured I injured my ankles quite badly
I had to have surgery so the second time
I had an operation I decided to take a
break from basketball to heal my foot
after basketball bjornsson wasn't sure
what to do with himself already
accustomed to a heavy training regimen
bjornsson decided to stay the course and
keep working out but instead of going
hard in the paint he went to work in the
weight room focusing his energy on
simply improving his body he told GQ I
just fell in love with the weights fell
in love with training hard started to
put weight on quite fast started to get
strong really fast I saw results over
the next few years weightlifting turned
into a healthy addiction for bjornsson
and the Icelander nearly doubled his
body weight of course weightlifting
alone can't turn a 240 pound basketball
player into the mountain that rides
it may not surprise you to learn that
the mountain that rides eats a mountain
of food every day breaking down his diet
to GQ he said I eat a lot of sweet
potatoes a lot of meat fish chicken good
fats like cocoa butter almonds I love
greens like spinach avocado broccoli I
eat very healthy overall sounds great
but how much is a lot exactly
but what we're going to talk about
bjornsson requires a total intake of
some 10 000 calories a day and there's
really only one way for him to fit all
that food into his stomach never stop
eating As bjornsson Told GQ if you don't
eat you don't grow it's just like
constantly work for me I have to eat
every two hours to maintain my body mass
we're not talking about grazing
throughout the day here either bjornsson
reckons he devours around six to eight
full meals a day even for a giant like
him such a feat is not easy especially
when he's at work shooting Game of
Thrones
though bjornsson focuses mostly on heavy
weightlifting and strength training he
doesn't always stick to the same
workouts instead he believes it's
crucial to mix things up according to
bjornsson there's more to being an
accomplished strong man than simply
putting on more muscle as he told the
New York Times you can't just be strong
you have to be quick you have to have
flexibility for that reason you can
sometimes find him out doing cardio
exercises such as swimming biking or
even jogging with his adorable
Pomeranian the freakish big and freakish
strong and quicker than you'd expect for
the man of that size
exercising the entire body is crucial to
seeing results especially when you're
already as huge as bjornsson he told
Men's Health when people ask me about my
routine it's hard to say because I
change it every week if you always train
the same way your body gets used to it
and you stop seeing results after a few
weeks bjornsin is big but he's not
interested in getting bigger instead
he's aiming to improve the body he
already has he told GQ getting bigger
isn't a big deal for me I don't want to
get bigger but having a nicer body and
being stronger is definitely something
I'm aiming for
on April 14 2019 the day of the season
premiere of the final season of Game of
Thrones ESPN's E60 documentary series
aired an interview that conducted with
bjornsson back in 2017 where the star
revealed that he has used steroids have
you ever used steroids
have I yes
uh yes I have both bjornsson and his
family expressed fears about his health
due to his extreme training regimen but
when pressed as to why he decided to
take steroids bjornson replied when you
want to be the best you do whatever it
takes
he finally won the world's strongest
manned competition in 2018.
Game of Thrones is one of the bloodiest
shows on television and it takes some
serious creative liberties with the
source material especially since it's
now surpassed the timeline and George
R.R Martin's books with a body count
that continues to climb with every
episode there have been quite a few
characters to bite the dust on the show
even if they're still alive and well in
Martin's World here are some of those
Dead Game of Thrones characters you may
still read about in The Winds of Winter
Catelyn Stark on the show Catelyn
Stark's sad tale ended when her throat
was slipped by the phrase at the Red
Wedding in the books though she's still
kicking around although we're not sure
you could call her alive instead of
letting Catelyn rest in peace after she
was brutally murdered George R.R Martin
had the phrase throw her body into the
green Fork of the Trident she drifted
Downstream until being discovered by the
direwolf nymeria it was being
unconsciously walked into by Aya Stark
My Maria pulled Catelyn from the river
and she was later found by Barrick
dondarian and the Brotherhood without
banners after thoros of Mia refused to
revive her because she was 3D is dead
Barrick gave Catelyn the kiss of Life
himself bringing her back at the cost of
his own life Undead Catlin became lady
stoneheart the new leader of the
Brotherhood who set forth on a bloody
campaign of Vengeance against anyone
even remotely associated with the phrase
the boltons or the Lannisters although
Game of Thrones hasn't been shy about
Reviving people from the dead even ones
that were already starting to rot like
the mountain lady stoneheart has never
gotten to come out to play and slay on
the show Ramsay Bolton Game of Thrones
fans may have breathed a sigh of relief
when the king of cruel finally bit the
dust in season six Ramsay Bolton's death
finally gave Sansa Stark some
satisfactory revenge and served up some
payback for all the times that sicked
his dogs on other people in the books
though Ramsay is still alive and
wreaking havoc on Westeros right
alongside his dad Roots Ramsey last
appeared in A Dance with Dragons after
wedding sansa's friend Jane Paul a
Steward's daughter that Littlefinger
trained to impersonate higher several
weeks after the nuptials are still alive
man's Raider disguised himself as above
to help Theon and Jane flee Winterfell
before they run into Stannis baratheon's
Army later Jon Snow who didn't know
Ramsey's bride wasn't the real Arya
received a letter from Ramsay demanding
the return of his wife and reek Ramsay
claimed to have defeated stannis's Army
and slain Stannis himself since we know
how much Ramsay loves to lie I grew up
on salt Cliff my Lord
I was only a boy when they took you away
it would be smart to take the bastard of
Bolton's words with a grain of salt
until we learn the truth in book six
which means we should probably consider
Stannis are still among the books living
for now as well
Shireen Baratheon there's no doubt that
Stannis Baratheon is a cold man in the
books and on the show as his thirst for
power comes at the expense of his
affection for his wife and daughter but
the show version of Stannis was so much
worse than it had to be in season 5 the
Red Witch Melisandre convinced Stannis
and his wife Solis to allow her to
sacrifice Shireen to the Lord of Light
so we might bless stannis's Army and
lead them to Victory against the boltons
instead half of stannis's army deserted
him Solis hung herself and Ramsey Bolton
easily wiped out the remaining soldiers
in battle all while poor Shireen became
a pile of dust on a pyre for readers the
sacrifice scene was probably a shock
since Stannis didn't take Shereen with
him to confront Ramsay and Martin's
version in fact Shireen Solis and
Melisandre were all left behind at
Castle black when his army marched with
instructions that the princess should be
left in charge if he fell as far as we
know Shireen still kicking it in a
castle even if her grayscale scars
frighten the wildlings according to the
Game of Thrones showing one as though
shireen's fiery death was one of the
three secrets that Martin revealed to
them about the future of his books so
even if living through shireen's demise
once was enough it might happen again on
paper soon enough Alyssa Thorne at the
end of season 5 Alistair Thorne managed
to organize a successful Mutiny against
Jon Snow and murdered him to claim the
title of Lord Commander his Reign was
short however after Melisandre
resurrected Jon and the wildlings
captured the mutineers John executed
Alistair for his portrayal in the books
Alice is still intensely dislikes Jon
but he's wisely avoiding giving Jon any
excuse to execute him I never once
disobeyed an order
loyalty is the foundation on which the
Night's Watch is built in fact Thorne
was still away from the wall when the
mutineers killed John so he had no part
in their treachery if Jon does get
resurrected in the books then he'll no
doubt execute the mutineers but Alistair
Thorne won't be on The Gallows with them
if I had to do it all over knowing where
I'd end up
Salman Baratheon at the end of season 6
King tommen gave new meaning to the name
of his Homestead King's Landing after
his wife Marjorie and the entire crowd
at the sept of Balor were blown up by
his mother Cersei he leapt from his
window at the red keep and fell to his
death while there was a tragic end for
the young king on the show he's still
alive and seated firmly on the iron
throne in the books for now at least the
book version of tommen is several years
younger than he is on the television
series and his primary hobbies are
signing anything the small Council puts
before him and of playing with the
kittens Marjorie gave him speaking of
his lady wife she's also still alive in
the story and while the two are married
in the books they most definitely have
not consummated their marriage bed as of
A Dance with Dragons tommen's future
rule was looking bright with his Uncle
Kevin as hand and Regent but Varys
nipped that in the bud when he murdered
Kevin and poisel considering that the
prophecy about cersei's children dying
in shrouds of gold still looms large for
all the Lannisters tommen's death has
probably imminent on paper as well
Marcella Baratheon unlike most of the
Lannisters Marcella was actually a sweet
and courteous princess who was
flourishing in Dawn and was quite
obviously in love with Prince Tristan
Martell in season six though Marcella
became one of the victims of alaria sand
and her daughters in her thirst for
revenge over Ober and martel's death
alaria gave Marcella a poisoned kiss
that later took her life and her uncle
father Jaime's arms in the books however
Marcella is alive in Dawn albeit Gravely
injured Cersei sent one of the
kingsguard to bring her back to King's
Landing but Prince doran's daughter
Arianne abducted her in an attempt to
have her crowned in opposition of tommen
in a confrontation with doran's
Guardsman one of ariane's accomplices
tries to murder myrcella to force a war
with the Lannisters but instead of
killing her his sword maimed her by
cutting off her ear and leaving a nasty
scar on her face as of A Dance with
Dragons Marcella was traveling back to
King's Landing accompanied by namira
sand who will be taking a seat on the
small Council reckon Stark on the show
rickon Stark joined his oldest brother
Robin death when he was killed by Ramsay
Bolton to kick off the battle of the
bastards he'd taken Refuge with the
umbers but that house betrayed him by
pledging fields and turning him over to
the boltons poor reckon in the books
some of rickon's story Remains the Same
OSHA took him and Shaggy Dog and they
split from Bran's group in order to keep
the Stark siblings safe last we heard of
him in A Dance with Dragons it fled
across the bay of seals where sir Davos
seaworth was set to go retrieve him
Hodor hold the door even though Hodor
was giving a devastating backstory and
final moment in season six the gentle
giant are still alive and well in the
books in A Dance with Dragons bran
mirror jojen Hodor and summer reached
the Cave of the three-eyed Raven
although they were attacked by whites
just as they arrived everyone survived
the encounter and the brand hasn't
encountered the night King in any of his
green dreams yet that doesn't mean Hodor
will make it through A Song of Ice and
Fire and scaves though according to
George RR Martin while the meaning of
his name would be the same in the books
the way its origin is revealed will be
different numbing Martin that probably
means it will just be as heartbreaking
though lancil Lannister cousin lancel's
future on the show went up in smoke when
he was killed in the season 6 finale
after being dispatched by the High
Sparrow to find Cersei landsill spotted
one of qyburn's child spies and followed
him into the Labyrinth of passages below
the sept of Balor there the child
shanked him and left him to watch as a
puddle of wildfire ignited to burn him
and the whole sept of Balor in the books
Lanzo was Gravely injured in the battle
of the Blackwater leaving him a frail
and poious man after his recovery he
joins the faith militant as a member of
the Warrior's Sons an order of knights
sworn to serve the high septon and when
he last appeared in the books it was to
serve as an escort for Cersei during a
walk of atonement and A Dance with
Dragons so whether he'll still be
punished by way of wildfire remains to
be seen which also leaves the fates of
the High Sparrow Marjorie and solores in
question for now as well
Walter free while fans of the show had
to wait several years for it Lord Walder
Frey finally got his comeuppance for the
events of the Red Wedding when he was
killed by Arya Stark in the season 6
finale she murdered his sons lothar and
black Walder before baking them into a
pie and serving it to their father while
disguised as a serving wench after she
revealed herself and killed him Aya took
his face and posed as Lord Walder in
order to organize A Feast for the
remaining free Kinsmen where she
murdered them all with pictures of
poisoned wine like the fine vintage that
ended the phrase the scenes were
delicious winter came for housefree as
satisfying as all that was though Lord
Walder is still hail and Hearty in the
books as of A Dance with Dragons the
prickly and treacherous octogenarian was
recently wed to another younger new wife
somehow we have to believe winter is
coming for him in the books too Olenna
Tyrell the queen of thorns Olenna Tyrell
received a relatively gentle death by
Game of Thrones standards in season 7
when she took the painless poison
offered to her by Jaime Lannister after
his army sacked highgarden displaying a
trademark sharp tongue the Tyrell
matriarch opted to take the poison
before revealing to Jaime that she was
the one responsible for the murder of
his son Joffrey
I wanted to know it was me like her
on-screen counterpart the book version
of Elena has taken leave of King's
Landing returning to highgarden the day
after marjorie's wedding to tommen she
hasn't been seen in the book since A
Feast for Crows so it's unknown if Elena
later returned to the capital after her
granddaughter was arrested by the High
Sparrow for her sake we hope not
benjen Stark Uncle benjen didn't have a
whole lot to do on Game of Thrones
despite lasting for Seven Seasons he was
mostly just portrayed as that benevolent
Uncle who rode in to rescue his nephews
from certain Doom beyond the wall and
after he was toppled by the night King's
Army in season seven he's probably not
coming back for another rescue mission
anytime soon in the books we never
actually get a real confirmation that
Benjamin was a mysterious Undead cold
hands but all the clues point to that
being the case he popped up to save
Simon Gilly from the whites as they fled
south from kruster's keep and he also
killed the night Watcher's mutineers
that attacked the Lord Commander Mormont
so while he still can't get past the
wall because of magical spells he's
probably still lurking out there in the
woods for the next time the three-eyed
Raven needs his help Littlefinger in the
season 7 finale of Game of Thrones
Littlefinger scheming finally caught up
to him when Sansa decided she'd had
enough of his meddling with the help of
an info bomb from bran and the slicing
skills of Aya Sansa managed to catch
Littlefinger in his own Web of Lies and
had him executed for trees reason and
the murder in the books however
Littlefinger is still trying to pull a
fast one on people for personal reasons
over in the area following his murder of
Liza Aaron littlefinger's latest plot is
to marry sander off with Robin's cousin
so that she can Ascend the throne and
Robin eventually succumbs to his chronic
illnesses a sample chapter from The
Winds of Winter indicates that Sansa
will have mixed feelings about this
Arrangement simultaneously working to
protect Robin while seducing his cousin
and since the woods witch prophesies
that Sansa would slay a Savage giant
which sounds like the sigil of House
Baelish he might not make it much longer
there either should I send word that'll
be delayed
viserion one of the most shocking
moments of season 7 came when Jon Snow's
Brigade of zombie captors had to be
rescued from a sea of white walkers by
Daenerys and their dragons in the midst
of the rescue the night King took him at
viserion and managed to slay the dragon
before resurrecting him as a new and
dead Mount that he could take through
the wall in the books viserion and his
siblings are safe for now one of the
martells tried to capture one of the
Dragons but failed miserably and when we
last saw viserion in A Dance with
Dragons he was happily roasting and
eating the plague-filled corpses that
the junkish Army were flinging into
Marine yum the rest of the undead as if
those names weren't enough to prove the
Game of Thrones showrunners have an even
heavier hand than George RR Martin some
of the other characters the author has
yet to kill off include barrist and
selmy Doran Martell brynden the
Blackfish Tilly Randall and dick on
tally lady Walter Bolton the sand snakes
thoros of Muir and the one one just to
name a few in other words if you thought
George RR Martin was Savage he's clearly
got nothing on the TV show's writers